تمام
لايف مندو
مساء الخير على حضراتكم اتمنى لكم ان شاء
الله ليله سعيده وايام كلها سعيده باذن
الله
اخونا ماندو قال الاسئله تبدا مع الحلقه
فيبدو انه اعطيت الدواء الاخضر
يلا على بركه الاول سؤال على طول من مستر
سلسله المحترم انصحكم بكتاب
عطب الذات للدكتور برهان غليون سوف تاخذ
فكره كافيه
ووافيه عن سوريا قبل الازمه وعن سبب فشل
المعارضه بدايه الثوره والله كتر خيرك
الدكتور برهان غليون حاضر
شكرا للنصيحه
غنيون
ما موقف امريكا وروسيا من السودان ودخول
فاجنر
ده اخونا عمر موقف امريكا
نقول موقف روسيا اوضح الحقيقه موقف روسيا
موقف دول كثيره بيبقى اوضح من الولايات
المتحده في السنوات الاخيره
روسيا تتمنى علاقات قويه جدا مع اي قوه
نافذه في السودان لانه اولا السودان هي
عندها اهتمامات بالسودان الذهب واحد منها
وليس اكثرها اهميه لكن عندها اهتمام
بالسودان لاسباب اخرى الموقع ثم الموقع ثم
الموقع روسيا تتمنى لو
يكون لها قاعده عسكريه على البحر الاحمر
ودي قصه نقشناها وتقدروا ترجعوا لاكثر من
حلقه في القناه وهناقشها في المستقبل ان
شاء الله كمان الموقع بيسمح لها ان هي
تتغلغل في دول كثيره في افريقيا ومنها
طبعا افريقيا الوسطى وفجر موجوده في
افريقيا الوسطى ومهتمه بالثروات الطبيعيه
اللي موجوده في افريقيا الوسطى ومهتمه
بمنطقه الساحل وكل دول افريقيا ودي قصه
برضو نقشناها قبل كده وبالتالي هي عاوزه
توثق علاقتها مع اي قوه غالبه في السودان
اذا كان هناك اكثر من قوه فهي تبقى حريصه
ان هي تمد يدها الى كل هذه القوى وهي لها
تجربه وسقط علاقتها مثلا بحكومه الشرق في
ليبيا
ولم تسيء لعلاقتها بحكومه الغرب في ليبيا
وان كانت العلاقه مع الشرق اكثر
اما امريكا دوله زي انا دايما بيجي له
الشعور في السنوات الاخيره
امبراطوريه ضخمه لكن اصبحت مرهقه فعندها
اهتمامات بكل 193 دوله واكثر الامم
المتحده مسجل فيهم 193 دوله انما عدد
البلدان اكثر يعني تايوان مش من الميه
تلاته وتسعين مثلا ما بيعتبروهاش عضو في
الامم المتحده فالدول 193 او العدد لما
يزيد شويه
البلدان التي ليست دوله امريكا لها ساي او
لها قول في شؤون كل هذه الدول
السودان ما لا تمثل اولويه كبيره للولايات
المتحده وانما مش عاوزه يعني
الاهتمام القليل الذي تعطيه اما لتعطيل
الصين اما لتعطيل الروس
اما للحفاظ على استقرار دول لا تتمنى ان
هي يصيبها
اذى كبير ده ياثر على حلفائها ما تتمناش
ان في فوضى تحصل مثلا وفي بلد بحجم مصر
100 مليون وهكذا ما عندهاش اهتمامات عميقه
بالسودان ولكن يعني
اهتمامات عامه كده يعني ما لهاش موقف واضح
قوي مش هتدي كتير من جهدها
وقتها للسودان
اخونا سرفايفر وولف صديق القناه القديم
مساء الخير استاذ سيد بخصوص الخلاف بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين حول رفع سقف
برايك ما هو الحل الامثل للتعامل مع هذه
المشكله التي قد تتحول لازمه اقتصاديه
عالميه
والله يا اخونا سيرفا انا بعتقد ان ازمه
سقف الدين هي
عرض
بيتم علاجه كل سنه
من غير صعوبه كبيره ولكن المرض مستقر
العرب بيقول ايه انه
في قانون في الولايات المتحده بدا في 1917
ثم تطور على مدار المئه سنه التاليه او
اكثر
القانون كان هدفه اثناء الحرب العالميه
الاولى انه يمنح الحكومه
مرونه التصرف يقول لها بدل ما كل شويه
ترجعي لي كحكومه علشان قانون عشان تاخدي
موافقه الكونجرس بغرفتيه على تمويل لمشروع
معين معك سقف خدي فيه الامور بحريه وطبعا
في يعني في حريه منضبطه يعني اذا كان
المساله عاوزه تحتاج الى رجل الكونجرس
اوكي اذا كانت يعني ده من صلاحيات السلطه
التنفيذيه فتفضلي
لكن اللي حصل انه على مدار سنوات طويله
بدات امريكا تستدين بشكل كبير جدا وكل مره
يوضع سقف يقول لهم ده الحد الاقصى لا يجب
ان تستديم تستدين مليم واحد او بنت واحد
الا بالعوده الى الكومنتس وتحدث المشاجره
كالعاده ما بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين
يعني ما بين السلطه القائمه اذا كانت
ديمقراطيه او جمهوريه وما بين المعارضه
اذا كانت يعني برضو جمهوريه وديمقراطيه
عاده المعارضه بتبقى رافضه ان الحكومه
يبقى عندها تنفق كما تريد لانه ده هيعزز
من شعبيتها
وهكذا يعني لكن اللي بيحصل ان هم دايما
بيوصلوا لحل لانه مستحيل ما يوصلوش لحل
لازم يبقى في حل لانه اذا رفضت المعارضه
تمرير زياده او رفع سقف الدين او تجميده
زي ما بيفكروا دلوقتي
معناها ان الولايات المتحده تتخلف عن
السادات ولما تتخلف عن السادات معناها ايه
معناها كل من اقرض الحكومه الامريكيه قد
لا يستطيع ان يحصل على امواله معنى كده ان
مفيش حد هيفكر في المستقبل انه يقرضها
التبعات هتكون خطيره وكبيره يعني ممكن
نتكلم عنها من هنا للصبح بس كل دي حاجات
الافتراضيه لان ده لم يحدث قبل كده ومن
غير المرجح بل من شبه المستحيل ان يحدث
ممكن يحصل تاخير يعني يتاخروا عن اقرار
سقف الدين اسبوع اثنين ثلاثه ثم يتم اخراج
سقف الدين هذا هو العرض الذي يتم علاجه
لكن المرض انه هذه الامبراطوريه الكبيره
هذه الدوله الكبيره لا تستطيع الا ان تعيش
على ديون وتسدد دين بدين كل شيء له نهايه
ما تقدرش تعيش كده
وبالتالي المشكله الكبيره يتم معالجه
المرض العرض لكن هيظل المرض وهو ان
الامريكان ينفقون اكثر مما يدخرون
زياد حسين اهلا وسهلا ما مستقبل سوريا
الديمقراطيه
بعد فوز اردوغان والله اخواننا الكرده
هيتعرضوا طبعا هذا لم يكن من امانيهم ان
يفوز اردوغان وان كنت واثق يعني ان هم
كانوا يعدون لهذا السراير والاكثر احتمالا
اردوغان من الشخصيات اللي هي يصعب ان
تهزمها في انتخابات لانه بيستخدم كل
الوسائل كل الوسائل حتى يبقى في مكانه وده
يعني ده اللي بيعملوه كل سياسيين مش
اردوغان فقط
ولكن تركيا وان كانت الممارسات
الديمقراطيه فيها افضل من معظم الدول
العربيه بكثير الى انها تظل يعني
الديمقراطيه معيبه وانه السلطه بتمارس
بتستغل وضعها او من هو قائم في السلطه
بحيث انه يجري في الانتخابات بكل الوسائل
الى صالحه
اكيد وضع الاكراد الكرد يعني
اللي انت بتتكلم عليهم في شمال سوريا
الكرد بصفه عامه لن يكونوا في احسن حال
خصوصا الجماعات اللي هي المعارضه خصوصا
الاحزاب المعارضه داخل تركيا وطبعا
الجماعات التركيه خارج الكرديه خارج خارج
تركيا وفي شمال سوريا زمن التحالف بتشير
طبعا يعني هيعانوا
هيجدوا صعوبه لكن هذه الصعوبات هم اعتادوا
عليها كثيرا وهيحاول اردوغان انه
يضغط على كل الاطراف الداعمه للكرد اذا
كان الولايات المتحده او اللي بتتعامل مع
الكورد زي روسيا او طبعا هيضغط على النظام
ويحاول مقايلته على حساب انه النظام ينقلب
على الجماعات الكرديه فامامهم تحديات
كبيره جدا في السنوات المقبله على الاقل
لي السنوات الخمسه اللي قاعد فيها اردوغان
ده حسام السلام عليكم عليكم السلام منور
جزاك الله خير الجزاء احمد الله يخليك يا
احمد سلام يا غالي عامل ايه طمني على
حضرتك عبد اللطيف ربنا يخليك يا عبد
اللطيف والله ربنا يخليك ويسعدك انا في
احسن حال والحمد لله
احمد حمدي انا احمد حمادي اسف الصاوي
لماذا مد وثيقه املاك الدوله لصندوق النقد
الدوري جنيه وليس بدولار ولماذا وما
تداعيات هذه الخطوه انا هستاذنك انا يعني
استاذنك انه
وثيقه ملكيه الدوله كلها عليها حلقه انا
اخرتها استاذنك انه ترجى الاجابه لانه هي
الحقيقه فيها تفاصيل كثيره ملكيه الدوله
فاستاذنك تكون الاجابه من خلال حلقه كامله
على نعرف اقتصادي اذا ما كانش يضايقك يا
استاذ احمد حاضر
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد معك سلمان سؤالي
ما هو سر الاصرار الشديد من قبل المغرب
على ضم الصحراء اقصد ما الذي تضيفه
الصحراء للمغرب هل هي غنيه بالثروات ام ان
لها موقع استراتيجي شكرا ده اخونا بيقول
سلمان اه
عده اسباب هو بيتكلم على الصحراء
اللي هي موضع او اهم قضيه
في على المستوى الاستراتيجي او الامن
القومي المغربي ليه المغرب مصره على
الصحراء اولا عندنا التلات
اكثر من مستوى يعني المستوى الاول انه ما
فيش بلد بيقول انه هذه الارض ارضي ثم
يتنازل عنها حتى لو كانت صحراء يعني
بلا قيمه وبالتالي
العامل الاول انها من وجهه نظر المغاربه
انها ارض المغربيه
وكل السياسيين المغاربه
استثمروا في هذه القضيه كثيرا بمعنى انه
يعني اشعلوا المشاعر القوميه تجاه مغربيه
الصحراء وعليه فما فيش سياسي مغربي يقدر
النهارده يقول انا ممكن
اعمل عليها او اتفاوض عليها
فالسبب الاول قناعتهم انها ارض مغربيه
السبب الثاني ان فيها ثروات كبيره جدا
الثروات الكبيره ديت مساحه ضخمه اظن انا
على ما اذكر حوالي 240 الف كيلو متر مربع
اتمنى يكون الذاكره لم تفوتني يعني مساحه
ضخمه فيها الكثير من المعادن وخصوصا
الفوسفات فيها اطلاله ضخمه جدا على المحيط
الاطلنطي وبالتالي مصايد اسماك سياحه الى
اخرهم ثم انه السيطره على الصحراء هتعزز
من قوه المغرب لانه تخيل انه العكس حدث
وانه بقت في جمهوريه صحراويه مناوئه
للمغرب او انها لم تعد تحت سيطره المغرب
قد ايه ده ممكن يهدد الامن القومي المغربي
ان يكون في دوله معاديه لي وترفضه موجود
على حدوده
ومدعومه من دوله قويه زي الجزائر
السلام عليكم بنت فلسطين اهلا وسهلا
بحضرتك
قلتم مره عديده من قبل ان الدوله
العثمانيه الدوله العلمانيه هي الحل
الوحيد لكن كيف تفسرون قرون المجد
الاسلامي في عهد الخلافه
خلافه الامويين والعباسيين والعثمانيين
حيث ازدهرت الحضاره عسكريه وقت اقتصاديا
والله سؤال جميل
اللي انا قلته انا بقول الدوله العلمانيه
هي الحل كنت ومازلت بقوله اولا انا هكلمك
الاول على التاريخ يعني هكلمك لاحقا عن
التاريخ انا بتكلم عن دوله حديثه الدوله
الحديثه دي معناها ايه معناها ان انت عندك
اقليات دينيه وعرقيه كثيره بتعيش تحت حدود
دوله قوميه دوله دوله قوميه يعني ايه يعني
بتقول او دوله وطنيه يعني بتقول الحدود دي
المئتين الف كيلو متر مربع والمليون كيلو
متر مربع او ايا كان المساحه اللي انت
بتحتلها دي بتضم كل الاديان وكل العراقيات
وكل يخضع لقانون واحد لا فضل لمسلم على
مسيحيين ولا يهوديا على
بوذيين الى اخره
اي حل تاني اي حل تاني غير علمانيه الدوله
مش علمانيه الافراد انت انت تبقى مسلم تقي
وانت مسيحي تقي وانت يهودي تقي طبعا اظلم
انت بتحترم الاديان كلها لكن الدوله نفسها
تسمح للجميع بممارسه اديانهم دون ان يتغول
احد على احد ده هو المفهوم العلماني طبعا
المفهوم ده
يبدو مقبول في حدود لانه بعض المتدينين
معتقد ان لديه الحق باعتباره ان هو صاحب
الديانه الوحيده الصحيحه انه يصادر على
حريات الاخرين
وبيعتبر تفسيره لدينه انه ده الكلام اللي
انا كنت بتكلم عليه في اكتر من حلقه انه
طالما انا دوله ذات اغلبيه مسلمه يبقى
خلاص لازم الاسلام يسود على حساب الاخرين
دوله بوذيه دوله وهكذا اندوسيه الى اخره
بالمناسبه كلهم
المتشددين من كل هذه الديانات بيفكر بنفس
الطريقه النتيجه ان انت هتصطدم باصحاب
الديانات الاخرى ان انت هتعملهم كمواطنين
من الدرجه الثانيه قد تهنئ بالقهر في انك
انت تفرض رؤيتك في دولتك لكن نفس بني
جلدتك من ديانتك ايا كانت ديانتك سوف
يعانون من الاضطهاد في ديانات اخرى وتصبح
المساله دايما فيها فوضى واضطرابات اقليه
منتصره في بلد ومغلوبه في بلد اخر
هنا العلمانيه قدمت حل وتم تجريبه ونجح
بدرجه كبيره العلمانيه زي اي فكره انسانيه
انت بتجربها بتنجح في دول يعني نجحت في
دول وجربت يعني كل الدول اللي احنا بنتكلم
عليها كنماذج استقرت ونجحت بتمارس
الديمقراطيه بتمارس العلمانيه العلمانيه
طبعا جزء من تركيبه كده ان علمانيه
ليبراليه دوله قانون الاخر ومش علمانيه
وخلاص يعني تحارب الدين وخلاص يعني
الدليل على انه العلمانيه بالشكل اللي انا
بقول عليه النمورس ناجح انه
انا مش فاكر مين والله المفكره العربي
اللي كان بيقول اذا كان الورد المفكر
الوردي العراقي او حد غيره كان قال انك
اذا سالت اي مسلم عن دوله علمانيه ودوله
دينيه يختاروا دوله دينيه ولكن اختاروا في
التصويت لكن يفضل ان يعيش في دوله علمانيه
وده على ارض الواقع ان الناس بتهرب من
قسوه الحياه في ظل النظم بتقول ان انا
دوله يعني
بطبق شرائع ديني وبتهرب الى الدول
العالميه حيث سياده القانون الى اخره
على كل الاحوال
دي قصه طويله لكن المؤكد ان في دوله حديثه
ما تقدرش ابدا تعيش الا في ظل نظام علماني
اديك مثال واحد واكتفي واذا اردتم نخصص
لها حلقه قل لي انت ممكن دوله زي الهند
تعيش ازاي دوله فيها مليار وداخله على 400
مليون فيها اكتر من 250 مليون مسلم وفيها
حوالي 900 مليون
هندوسي وفيها بقى اقليات لا تعد ولا تحصى
من يهود ومسيحيين وسيخ وكل الاقل يعني
تفتكر لو انه
الهندوس وبعضهم بيطالب بكده انه هذه
دولتنا
ويجب ان احنا بنعامل كل الناس دول على
انهم مواطنين من الدرجه الثانيه لو ارادوا
ان هم يطمسوا هويه الاقليات دي ممكن
يعيشوا ازاي هتلاقي ان عندك مذابح عندك
فوضى الى اخره ده اللي انا اقصده انت
بتتكلم على التاريخ التاريخ اللي انت
بتقول عليه بتتكلم على فتره طويله جدا
فيها فترات جيده وفيها فترات يجب ان نخجل
منها مش تخجل منها كمسلمين ولكن نخجل اللي
بيدافع عنها لانها كانت امبراطوريات مارست
العنف بشكل عنيف قل لي انت بتتكلم على
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه امبراطوريه
العثمانيه دخلت العالم باعتبارها دوله
مسلمه قل لي ايه اللي كانت بتعمله يجعلها
امبراطوريه اكثر فضيله من الامبراطوريه
البري او الامبراطوريه الفرنسيه او غيرهم
انه الايمان بيصلي صلاته لربه انه الامام
يزكي هذا له ان انت عملت نظام زكاه مثلا
مثلا ما عملتش الضرايب ده شكل مختلف من
اشكال الحكم لكن جوهر القصه ان تكون اكثر
عدلا اكثر تقدما اكثر لبلا ده ما بيتحققش
بان انت تعلن ان انت عندك شريعه ما انت
لازم تكون انت عاوز تعمله لان كل الاديان
بتدعو للفضاء يعني الفضيله مش حكر على دين
معين الفكره في الممارسه
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
غازت معظم الدول الاسلاميه لو هي نشرت
الاسلام لو افترضنا ان ده مطلوب وان انت
تنشره في في طب انت غازيت مصر وغازيت
المغرب لا المغرب انا اسف انت غازيت
تونس ومصر ودخلت في الحروب مع ايران ورحت
كنت بتنشر الاسلام طب ماذا فعلت حين دخلت
هذه البلدان اكثر من انت عملت ممثل لك ثم
اديرت هذه البلاد كما كانت انه يقدم
الولاء
للباب العالي ويجمع
اللي هي
الاموال يعني اللي بتدفع للباب العالي
الامبراطوريه العباسيه والامويه هي
امبراطوريات يعني كانت ملكيه عضوض يعني ما
فيش فيها حاجه تقول ان هي كانت تختلف او
اكثر نبلا من امبراطوريه اخرى كانت تعيش
معها يعني لا اكثر لبلا ولا اقل ولا هي
اكثر
شراسه يعني او عنفا كان فيها وعليها
يتساوى في ذلك مع غيرها ولما بيجي فتره
تبقى نبيله جدا والناس شايفين فيها الحاكم
مثال عظيم في التقوى والنبل دي مساله
شخصيه ورجل مسلم تقي مؤمن عنده قدره طب
ولما بيجي سفاح باسم الاسلام بيقتل ويسر
ويعمل كل شيء يعني
هذا في حدود علمي والله اعلم ومستعد
للنقاش وزي ما بيقولوا بالانجليزي
مستعد ان اسمع وجهات نظر اخرى
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد انا اسمي عبد
المغري المغني بضم المين سؤالي هو انه ليش
الاردن والاردنيين ما لهم نصيب بحلقاتك
وحواراتك
والله
حاضر يعني انا انا عندي
لا يعني مش مقصود هو ايه انا اقول لك انا
بفكر ازاي وقد اكون مخطئ اولا
القضايا الكتيره مهمه عاده القنوات وانا
كنت لسه بتكلم مع احد الاصدقاء يعني
اسالني على قناه عاوز يعملها فبنصحه الا
يعني يقرر ما فعلته انا انا بدات ايه انا
عندي اهتمامات بالعلاقات الدوليه
بالاقتصاد بدات الاثنين وبعدين الاقتصاد
ده مش الاقتصاد المصري الاقتصاد السعودي
بنتكلم على قضايا متنوعه ثم شؤون العلاقات
الدوليه متنوعه ده كان مجهد جدا جدا
ما عرفتش اتراجع عنه غير بان انا افصل
قناه نعرف اقتصاد بحاول اعمل خطوات مشابهه
لكن في النهايه الساحه كبيره ايه اللي انا
بعمله ان انا بتناول الدول اللي بيبقى
عندها سياسه خارجيه نشطه جدا يعني مثلا
بلد زي الكويت انا لم اتحدث عنه مره واحده
طب هو الكويت مش مهم الكويت بلد مهم بس
الكويت شانه داخلي اكتر من تاثيره في
العالم الخارجي هو مش حابب انه يكون له
تواجد مهم وكبير بلد زي سلطنه عمان بلد
مهم عاوز توكيه بلو بروفايل ويعمل من وراء
الكواليس التركيز على الدول اللي عندها
سياسه خارجيه نشطه الاردن طبعا عنده سياسه
خارجيه نشطه
ما هواش نفس مثلا انه بيلعب دور
يعني اجرسيف او سلف السلف بالمعنى
الايجابي مش بالمعنى السلبي زي مثلا
الامارات زي قطر زي السعوديه قناه طلعت في
2016 2017 كانت الغلبه في هذه على هذه
الساحه كانت لي تركيا اسرائيل ايران بعض
دول الخليج وهم دول اللي حاضي وطبعا
باستثناء الدول الكبرى اللي هي الدول
الوقت المهمه يعني دول اللي حاضيوا النسيب
الاكبر انا اسف ان انا اقتلت في الشرح لكن
يعني نتشرف بالحديث عن المملكه الاردنيه
الهاشميه الغريبه ان انا عاوز اقول لك ان
انا عندي اهتمام كبير جدا جدا جدا بتاريخ
المملكه
ووثائقها اللي بتكشف لنا كتير من اسرار
المنطقه
وليس كل ما يعرف يقال لكن حاضر
تكلم عن اقتصاد الجزائر اقتصاد الجزائر يا
صديقي في مشكله في استاذ يوسف انه هو
البلد بلد عنده ثروات ضخمه جدا لكنه
مش اقتصاد مفتوح يعني ما عندوش استثمارات
خارجيه كتير معندوش مثلا ما عندوش بورصه
نشطه ما عندوش حاجات كتيره لامور يعني
مركز كتير على اقتصاد الطاقه وانه الطاقه
دي بتروله وغازه يضر عليه عوائد وهذه
العوائد شويه يعني
مش اقتصاد منفتح
وتقاريره كتيره موجوده وعنده استثمارات
خارجيه كتير يعني فشويه
مساله عاوزه تفسير يعني
ايه هي الحاله الجزائريه حاله خاصه بكل ما
فيها ومالات حس انه سياسه الخارجيه الان
يعني امتداد قوي جدا جدا لفتره الخمسينات
والستينات بما في ذلك من مزايا له من عيوب
يعني
محمد ماهر بما تفسر عدم المعارضه
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه للمفاعلات النوويه
المصريه والتركيه ومعارضتهم للمفاعلات
النوويه السعوديه رغم القدره النظريه على
الاستخدام العسكري لمصر مين قال اخونا
محمد الفيتو الامريكي الاسرائيلي الواضح
احيانا والمفهوم ضمنا عرقل البرنامج
النووي المصري
لسنوات طويله جدا اديني تفسير واحد لماذا
ونحن في العام 2023 لا نجد مفاعلا نوويا
كبيرا في مصر حتى مشروع المفاعل اللي جاري
ما زال يعني
انما ليه لو تم هيبقى بعد مثلا ثلاث اربع
سنين اذا تم تم بان حجم وباني مواصفات
وليه ما تمش في كل السنوات الماضيه دي
مساله خطيره للامريكان وللاسرائيليين
ودائما كان عندهم فيتو عرقلوه بشكل
ليس سرا يعني طوال السنوات الماضيه
بالنسبه للمفاعلات التركيه
برضو هيبقى زيها زي المفاعل المصري
يعني حريصين عقلوه لسنوات طويله ولما جاء
الدور على انه تركيا مصره على مفاعلات
برضو زي مصر تركيا لجات الى الروس وبرضو
تحت ضوابط كبيره جدا وتعهدات الا يتحول
هذا البرنامج ابدا الى عسكري
لا الفيديو موجود احيانا بيعجزوا يعني
يمارسوا ويعجزوا حتى الان لم يعجزوا حتى
الان الفيتو تفضل القدرات النوويه حتى
السلميه المصريه والتركيه وكل دول المنطقه
محدود اللي افلت من كده ايران وتقدر طبعا
اذا ضميت لدول المنطقه باكستانيه
السعوديه
هي ما كانش فيه يعني ما كانش في فيتو
اسرائيلي امريكا على السعوديه لان ما كانش
من طموحات السعوديه انها تعمل طاقه نوويه
السعوديه تاخرت في امور كثيره جدا جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا ثم استفقت تفتح يعني
اسكوبه اهتماماتها على كل شيء ده شيء جميل
جدا واتمنى انه يكلل بالنجاح بدا تعمل
بتفكر في برنامج نووي سلمي وطبعا لا تخفي
تهديداتها للعالم الخارجي بانه اذا ايران
تمكنت من امتلاك قنبله نوويه انا كمان
هطور قنبله نوويه الامريكان بيشكوا ان هم
بيطوروا اسلحه
تكنولوجيا صواريخ
بمساعده الصين لا اعرف مدى دقتها لكن
منشور الكلام ده من سنه 2021
ماشيين في كله بقى في السياحه الدينيه
وغير اسف يعني السياحه غير الدينيه اللي
هي لان السياحه الدينيه كانت موجوده ولو
ان بعض السعوديين بيزعلوا من كلمه السياحه
الدينيه بس ده تصنيفها العلمي يعني لانه
بيقول دي فرائض واحنا بنستقبل لكن طبعا هي
بزنس ناس بتستفيد منه مش بيزنس
هي تصنيفها كده على بجوار الاماكن الدينيه
فانت عندك طيران بيشتغل وعندك وتجاره الى
اخره يعني وعندك داخلين في كل حاجه تعدين
وصناعه وبينافسوا دلوقتي كل الاماكن الحبس
التجاريه زي الامارات وغيرها
اخونا داوود هل فوزي اردوغان يتم
يتم في مصلحه اوروبا يكونوا في مصلحه
اوروبا كون علاقته بالروس تجعله يصلح
كوسيط انا اعتقد ان فوز اردوغان مش في
مصلحه علاء اوروبا ولا الغرب كله ومش في
مصلحه دول كثيره
انا اعتقد النفوس اردوغان والله بامانه
انا بقوله قد اكون ليس في مصلحه اردوغان
اردوغان يعني انك تدخل السلطه تختار انت
تدخل السلطه وامتى تخرج منها ممكن تختار
انت تدخل لان ممكن تبقى المهمه صعبه جدا
فتقول انا مش هقدر ادخل في الفتره دي ودي
شفناها في بعض الفترات ان في سياسي معين
يرى ان الفتره ديت من الصعب اذا كان له ان
يدخل ان من الصعب ان يدخل انما ما شفناش
سياسي بيخرج ابدا طائعا من السلطه الراجل
اضع عشرين سنه فعل كل شيء يمكن ان يسجله
له التاريخ
لكن بدا
بانجازات ضخمه اخمجان عشر سنوات ثم
اعقبتها سنوات اخرى ظل الرجل برضو في يعني
اوج عطائه له عليه ثم في السنوات الاخيره
بيعاني عنده مشكلات كتيره مشكلات اللي
بترتبط بطول بقاء الانسان اكثر من اللازم
في السلطه هل ده ينطبق على اردوغان فقط
ينطبق على اردوغان وينطبق على كل
السياسيين اللي بقوا في السلطه بما انه
الدساتير بيتم التلاعب بها او بما انه
الحياه السياسيه هشه ما فيهاش نفس قوه
مثلا الحياه السياسيه اللي موجوده في دول
مستقره بتضع فترات معينه
لا مش هو لوحده انما انا بقول بتسالني عن
اردوغان كان الافضل له كثيرا الافضل
لتركيا كثيرا انه يكتفي بما قدمه ويكتفي
بالعشرين سنه الماضيه ولكن هذا لم يحدث
وطبعا طول بقاؤه في السلطه بيضعف المعارضه
وتصبح المعارضه غير قادره على منافسته وهو
في تعبير بالانجليزي بيقول لك كيرفول
احترس مما تتمناه ان تتمنيت ان انت تبقى
في السلطه بدا في اليوم الاول عنده كابوس
التضخم اللي هو صنعه بسياساته عنده كابوس
العلاقات المتشابكه هل الى متى سوف يظل
كده يعني يرقص على الحبال بين الغرب
والشرق عمليه صعبه جدا لكن في النهايه
اللي بيساعدوا ان تركيا بلد كبير جدا بلد
بالغ الاهميه لدول كثيره في العالم
هو الراجل عنده مهارات كبيره اتمنى ان هي
تساعده في مرور في تجاوز هذه العقبات عوده
لسؤال حضرتك اختصار لا هذا لم يكن خبرا
جيدا للاوروبيين او لمعظم الاوروبيين هذا
لم يكن خبرا جيدا للولايات المتحده هذا
ليس خبرا جيدا
الرئيس بشار الاسد وان كان خبرا جيدا
لقطاعات اللي هي بتحظى بدعمه في سوريا ليس
خبرا جيدا للاكراد ليس خبرا جيدا لحوالي
48% من الترك الذين لم يصوتوا لهم
هل طالبان والمجاهدون الافغان نفس التنظيم
ام لا يعني هو اصل الطالبان ده خرجت من
المجاهدين الافغاني يعني مجموعه القوى
الاسلاميه او التنظيمات اللي كان بيغلب
عليها الطابع الاسلامي اللي رفضوا اللي
رفضوا
الحكومه الشيوعيه اليساريه اللي كانت
موجوده في
وثاروا عليها ولما دخل الاتحاد السوفيتي
بداوا يقاوموا الحكومه اللي موجوده
والاتحاد السوفيتي ثم وجدت الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وحلفائهم في المنطقه زي
السعوديه ومصر وبعض دول الخليج فرصه ان هم
يزدادوا الاتحاد السوفيتي بدعم قاده
المجاهدين طالبان اللي هم طلبه المدارس
الدينيه نشاوا في هذه الفتره اللي كانت
يعني فيها جماعات كتيره او زعماء او امراء
حرب بس بيحملوا يعني شعارات اسلاميه
نشات في حضن هذه الجماعات لما انتهت الحرب
وبقت في فوضى وحروب داخليه بين المجاهدين
او الجهاديين او امراء الحرب الافغان زي
ما تحب تسميهم يعني
نشات حركه طالبان ورات في الفوضى قدرت ان
هي تعيد الهدوء والامن في افغانستان ولكن
بالاسلوب اللي هي بتعمل به دلوقتي اللي هو
شكلها الحالي
اللي طبعا ما يقدرش يحرك افغانستان
الى الامام ابدا يعني
ايجابي ايجابي للمنطقه العربيه حسين بيقول
اللي هو ايه بقى اللي هو اردوغان
بس هو ايجابي او غير ايجابي انت بالمناسبه
ده برضو نسيت يعني هو لو كان اردوغان خرج
من السلطه يعني اولا التركيه داخله في
ملفات كتيره جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا وده واحد
من الملامح الاساسيه لفتره حكم اردوغان
انه جعل حول تركيا من دوله يعني
اسيويه اوروبيه حليفه محدوده التاثير يعني
على العالم الى دوله
طالعه او منخرطه في امور الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا واسيا اسيا بكل فئتها وخصوصا
اسيا الوسطى ومنطقه القوقاز
واوروبا كل مكان يعني وبالتالي عشان تقول
مفيد او مش مفيد عاوز كل حاله لوحدها كل
حاله ممكن تناقشها انما في كل الاحوال لا
يجب ان يكون احدا واهما انه النهارده لو
كان اردوغان كان خارج من السلطه كان هيجي
معارض اخر هيعمل على مستوى السياسه
الخارجيه التغييرات الجذريه تماما لانه في
مقتضيات للامن القومي التركي
المقتضيات ديت كانت خامله لان التركيه كان
بلدا ضعيفا لو احنا بنتكلم مش ضعيفه يعني
اضعف مما هو عليه الان الان مع وجود
البرلمان الاكثر تشددا من حيث النزعه
القوميه نحن تركيا نحن البلد الذي يريد ان
يكون بلدا عظيما اي رئيس كان هيكون خاضع
لهذا البرلمان اللي هو بالغ القوميه باري
ناشونال وبالتالي كان هو لن برضو ان يقدم
تنازلات زي ما الناس متخيلينها لن يكون
حمامه وديعه ولكن كان يمكن ان يعالج بعض
خلافاتهم مع دول الجوار بطريقه اهدى خذ
مثال كان ممكن جدا يتفاهم مثلا مع السويد
ويدخلها حلف شمال الاطلسي في مقابل انه
يعني يتفاهم معاها يعني
بدل ما يعرقلها ويغضب ويغضب السويد ويغضب
دول حلف شمال الاطلسي كان يمكن ان يكون
التفاوض مع بشار الاسد اكثر يسرا كان يمكن
ان يكون اقل تشددا تجاه الجامعات الكرديه
ويحصل منها على تفهمات لا تخاطبهم ولا
تهدد تركيا كان الوضع هيكون اهدى لكن مش
هتنتفي او هتتراجع لوجود التركي تماما في
كثير من دول العالم يعني
جوده الصوره سيئه جدا ايه الحكايه سيئه
جدا
الاول بس طيب ماندو بيقول على عهدته كانت
الصوره سيافه
عمرو كان موجود كانت الصوره حلوه المره
اللي فاتت صح
جاء العميل
محمد ما انت قاعد بتشرب قهوه يا عم
تحاول الطبقه الحاكمه في العراق ان تكون
جسرا بين ايران والدول العربيه لكن هذا
سوف يفشل بالسب تنحيتهم للصدر وربما يؤدي
الى ازمه سياسيه اشد من السابق في العراق
والله رايي كل الاحترام
سؤالي بالنسبه للقمه العربيه هذه القمه
كانت مختلفه اولا كان اهتمام كبير للقمه
لم نرى حكام النائمون وكان توافق كبير
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت حاضره بقوه كيف
تابعت القمه العربيه
وما اهم ما استنتجتهم ايها القمه العربيه
كانت قمه يعني
حدث يستحق ان نتوقف عنده انما في لقطات
يعني اللقطه الاولى طبعا انه قطر ما زالت
مثلا على موقفها من الرئيس بشار الاسد
عوده رئيس بشار الاسد
رقم واحد ده نقطه معناها بتقول انه في
سنوات
يعني نهايه حقبه زمنيه عوده بشار الاسد
بتقول ان احنا بنطوي سنوات يعني كانت
ساخنه وملتهبه بدات مع ما سمي بثورات
الربيع العربي
انسحاب
الامير القطري اثناء الكلمه بيقول انه
مازال على موقفه من بشار الاسد وبيقول انه
السياسه القطريه مصره او دي مش حاجه وحشه
يعني ايه ان مصر ان يكون له ملامحه
المستقله تماما عن كثير من دول المنطقه
ومنها الدوله الاكبر في الخليج اللي هي
السعوديه
يعني الجزائر طبعا لم تكن سعيده انه شعرت
انه تم
تهميشها في الاعداد للقمه ده كان واضح جدا
وشعرت انه
مات طالبت به يعني بعوده سوريا العام
الماضي وضغطت عليه لم يتحقق الا حين اصبحت
القمه في المملكه فيعني الجزائر
يعني موقفها او
انزعاجها مما جراك انها واضحا ايضا
استضافه الرئيس الاوكراني كان ملمحن في
تاثير يعني انه
انه يعني
انه كان رغبه في عدم ازعاج الامريكان يعني
جاء بشار الاسد لم يكن ذلك ده تفسير
الوحيد لانه اصلا انت هتعمل انت تستضيف
الرئيس الاوكراني ليه يعني علشان يعرف
قضيته ما معظم الدول ديت واخده موقف واضح
انه لا شان لنا بهذا مش هيقدمه حاجه
للرئيس الاوكراني
وعلاقه معظم الدول بروسيا علاقه قويه فانا
تقدير يعني انه للامريكان انه احنا
عارضناكم في امور كثيره ونحن نرغب في الله
يعني نخطبكم الى في علاء كل المستويات اذا
احنا استضفنا حليفكم الرئيس الاوكراني
يتحدث كما يشاء انت مش هتقدر تلعب دور
الوسيط تقدر تلعب دور الوسيط في انك انت
مثلا في تبادل السجناء ممكن تقدم مساعدات
ممكن انما هتلعب وساطه في ايه ما فيش دوله
في العالم نجحت وصعب ان في دوله في العالم
تنجح في اداء الدور الوس اطه
ما لم تكن كل الاطراف راغبه والولايات
المتحده غير راغبه في انهاء الحرب في هذه
اللحظه
هل يبالغ الغرب في تقدير سوء اوضاع
المواطنين في كوريا الشماليه ام ان الوضع
هناك صعب بالفعل
احمد محمد اصل حكايه الوضع صعبه او الوضع
ميسور دي عمليا نسبيه يعني انت
تعودت على ايه فاذا الناس تعونت طبعا اكيد
الاوضاع انت لما تيجي تقارن بلد زي يعني
كوريا الشماليه وكوريا الجنوبيه هتلاقي
بلد طبعا في فرق في تعداد السكان لصالح
كوريا الجنوبيه بس بتلاقي بلد الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي له حوالي بتاع عشرين خمسه
مليار دولار وجاره بتتكلم انه عنده اقتصاد
تريليوني يتجاوز التريليون دولار انت
بتتكلم على
بلد يعني عايش حياه
يعني متقشفه جدا جدا جدا لانه معظم
اقتصاده رايح في اتجاه الحرب والقدرات
العسكريه فقط
عشان تبالغ لازم تعيش وانت ما تقدرش تعيش
في كوريا الشماليه لان الاجانب بمفرد
عليهم قيود ضخمه جدا جدا جدا وبالتالي
اللي انت بترصده من الفرين من كوريا
الشماليه من الاجانب القليلين المسموح لهم
بالزياره لفترات قليله انما المنطق يقول
ان بلد بهذه الظروف صعبه ان يكون
انه بيعيش عيشه عظيمه يعني اكيد الحياه
صعبه في كوريا الشماليه نقطه تانيه بقى هل
الناس اعتدت على كده هم لم يروا عالما اخر
فانت بتعتاد على اكل معين لبس معين حياه
معينه تتاقلم معها ما انت ما شفتش غيرها
يعني
هل صحيح ان سياسه الانفتاح ايام السادات
هي سبب خراب الاقتصاد وما رايك في نموذج
دوله التنميه مثل الصين واثيوبيا
وسنغافوره هل ممكن ان ينجح في مصر انا
طبعا بتتكلم انا ما اعرفش هنا نموذج دوله
التنميه
انت ضربت امثله بدول مختلفه
كل دوله لها ظروفها يعني ما اعرفش ان هذا
النموذج يجمع الدول الثلاث قد يكون وانا
لا اعلم بس انا ما اعرفش ده انما انت
السؤال اللي اعرفه هل الانفتاح الاقتصادي
هو اللي تم ايام السادات الانفتاح
الاقتصادي كانت مصر دوله اشتراكيه بتلعب
الدوله فيها الدور الاساسي في اداره
الاقتصاد وبتعمل ما يسمى بين اللي هو
الاقتصاد التاشيري او النظام اللي هو
للدوله تحط خطط وتسعى لتنفيذها والقطاع
الخاص بيلعب ادوار بسيطه مع قدوم السادات
بدا يعني في نهايه ايام السادات بدا انه
بعد حرب اكتوبر وبعد
يعني في منتصف السبعينات كده بدا يتكلم
على الانفتاح الانفتاح يعني ايه يعني ان
الدوله تنسحب نسبيا من النشاط الاقتصادي
تسمح بالتدخل بنشاط اكبر للقطاع الخاص
بدات الاسواق تنفتح للاستيراد طبعا ساعد
في ذلك انه الطفره البترول اللي قاعد بعد
حرب اكتوبر
ورغبه دول خليجيه في ان هي تاتي يعني
بعض دول الخليج يعني او بعض الاستثمارات
الخليجيه في فتره قبل ان تسوء الاوضاع مره
اخرى مع السادات
او مع مصر فكان هو ده المقصود بالانفتاح
الاقتصادي انت بتقول الانفتاح هو سبب
الخراب لا
الاقتصاد المصري كان بيعاني قبل الانفتاح
وعانى بعد الانفتاح ثم انه مبارك قعد
حوالي 30 سنه في السلطه الاقتصاد المصري
يعني كان ما بين انه يكون عنده معاناه
ومعاناه اقل يعني لكن عمره ما كان مزدهر
يعني
الاسباب في كده تقدر بقى نتكلم عنها ايام
كثيره جدا جدا جدا ولكن دايما عندنا في
مشكله في مصر
مشكله كبيره لكن واحده من الاسباب الواضحه
جدا ان انت بلد من حيث الظروف اللي فرضت
عليه خرج دايما من ازمه ليدخل في ازمه
تخيلات حاده جدا خد على مدار التمانين سنه
اللي فاتت تقريبا او السبعين سنه اللي
فاتت ملكيه بقت جمهوريه من نظام راس مالي
الى نظام اشتراكي ثم من اشتراكي الى نظام
راس مالي
ثم في نفس الفتره ديت انت عندك
ما حدث في 52 تسمي ثوره 70 انقلاب زي ما
انت عاوز ثم عندك في الفتره ديت بعد حرب
48 انت كنت خارج منها انت عندك العدوان
الثلاثي 56 عندك حرب 67 حرب 73 اراضيك
راحت فيه 67 وكان كل جهودك وكل حياتك
لاستخداع الارض الاسترجاع الارض في 67 في
73 ثم
خرجت من الحرب الرئيس بيقول لك انا ما
عنديش مليم واحد فيه خزائني
ثم
بعد فتره هدوء يعني لها وعليها في فتره
مبارك انت كان عندك البنيه التحتيه على
الارض تقريبا بعد كده انت جاء عندك ثوره
او يعني ثورات الربيع العربي 2011 ثم 2013
ثم يعني سياسات مختلفه
بعضها كان ايجابي وبعضها غير ايجابي في ظل
حكومه الرئيس السيسي في حاجات كانت
ايجابيه وفي حاجات سلبيه عندك حاجات خارج
عن ارادتك وحاجات داخل ارادتك اللي داخل
ارادتك انه انت بلدغ للاستثمار ما قدرتش
تقنع الناس ابدا بالاستثمار الخارجي فيك
ابدا بحيث ان انت تبقى بلد زي دول اخرى
ناس بتستثمر فيها وهم مرتاحين مش قادر
تنجح كده تعقبت حكومات كثيره ولكن انت
عجزت انك تحسن من التشريعات وتحسن من
البنيه التحتيه وتحسن من مجموعه قوانينك
بحيث تكون بلد جانب للاستثمار
هل يبلغ
هناك تقارير تفيد بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كانت تبلغ الولايات المتحده بكل
خطوه في مفاوضتها مع بواسطه الصينيه
فلماذا ذلك انا ما اعرفش ده حصل عشان تقول
لي فلماذا فانا ما اعرفش لا اعرفه حاجه
واحده بس ان الامريكان ابلغوا بانه هناك
مفاوضات
بوساطه صينيه وده امر مش عجيب ولا حاجه
يبقى انت مش بتبلغ مثلا بلد
الولايات المتحده تظل حليفه للسعوديه
والحاجه بينهما كبيره والولايات المتحده
هي القوه الاكبر في العالم لا تستطيع ان
انت يعني تتجاهلها تماما انما انت سعيد في
اتجاه وابلغتهم يعني ما فيش ما فيش حاجه
غريبه في ذلك انما سؤالك يوحي كانه هم
كانوا طوال الوقت على اتصال يعني شيء مريب
ما فيش حاجه مريبه في المساله ولا حاجه
يعني
وبعدين انا عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه
الامريكان دول عندهم برضو مشكله ان هو
طوال الوقت
يعني انت كنت بتسالني حد كان بيسالني في
اول سؤال صديقي اللي بيسال على انه الموقف
من سوريا الموقف في السودان اسف الموقف في
سوريا الموقف في السودان دايما هتلاقي انه
امريكا في بعض الملفات العمليه عائمه فيها
يعني هم يتضرروا ولا يستفيدوا في حاله
هدوء بين السعوديه وايران معظم الامريكان
احنا نستفيد امريكا كامريكه نستفيد احنا
ايه لا نستفيده ان البلدين يفضلوا يضربوا
في بعض والبلدين وبالتالي انا ابقى في
حاله الطور وانا عندي التزامات تجاه حلفاء
الى اخره يعني ويبقى في امكانيه اكتر انه
حليف الاساسي يتضرب في اسرائيل انا مستفيد
من التهدئه
ده اتجاه اتجاه تاني يقول لك لا انت والله
لو كل الدول ديت وطرت علاقتها مع ايران
اقدر احاصرها واضغط عليها بشكل اكبر
وانتزع منها ده كان توجه بتقوله ترامب ولم
تقوله اسرائيل مش اسرائيل جناح معين في
اسرائيل اللي هو اليمين المتطرف اللي
مسيطر على اسرائيل في العشرين سنه الاخيره
يعني
فدائما هتلاقي امريكا ممكن دايما يعني في
القضايا اللي هي مش
مش بالغه الوضوح زي ايه بلاغه الوضوح زي
الصين لازم نحجم من الصين ولا نتهاون فيه
ده امر بالغ الوضوح القضايا البالغه
الوضوح في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه في
السنوات الاخيره ليست كثيره
الاداره رجاء
الاسئله ممنوعه انا اسف مش عارف يعني ايه
يا حسام
الاسئله ممنوعه انا مش عارف يعني ايه
ما فيش حاجه ممنوعه
التصحيح الثاني انه لا يمكن لشعب للخروج
ضد النظام في نفس الوقت بكل المدن بسبب
القبض الامنيه والخوف
حتى انت لا تستطيع
ماشي انا اسف مش فاهم ايه هو التصحيح
الاولاني طيب
حماده عباس بيقول هلا العمله التركيه
تتحسن بعد فوز اردوغان هي العمله نزلت في
قبل الفوز وبعد فوزه
واقتربت من العشرين انا متابعتهاش امبارح
واول امبارح يعني وانا اكيد يعني ما انا
ما بستثمرش في تركيا مش مشكله يعني ان
العمله لكن اقصد اقول ان هي كانت سبب واضح
انه كان نزول العمله يعني انخفاض لا هو
تعبير عن مخاوف مستثمرين في تركيا من
النفوس اردوغان يعني الاستمرار في سياساته
غير التقليديه في التعامل مع الاقتصاد ودي
قصه اتكلمنا فيها واختصار كده انه استقرت
النظريه الاقتصاديه
عن ارتفاع الاسعار او التضخم بيكون ناتج
عن
ان انت عندك ركود فانت بتخفض الفوائد
علشان تشجع الناس على الاقتراض وبالتالي
الاستثمار انت بتشجع اللي بتخفض الضرائب
عشان تشجعهم على العمل لانك انت عندك
انكماش نشاطك الاقتصادي قليل انما لو عندك
النشاط الاقتصادي عالي وانت بتعمل كده
يبقى انت عامل زي عربيه
او زي اسف يعني فرن حريق حريق او النار
شغاله في فرن البوتاجاز ولا الفرن الكبير
اللي انت بتعمله في مصانع الحديد وغيرها
وانت هو مشتعل وانت عمال تزيده وقود
النتيجه انه هيوصل الى حد ينصهر الفرن
نفسه
ليه اردوغان بيعمل كده دي قناعاته اللي
اتكلمنا عنها وعنده قناعه ان ده افضل حل
بس انا عندي تفسير ثاني الحقيقه غير
قناعاته اللي بعض الاقتصاديين كان بيقول
عليها ساخرا
ايردوغانوميكس يعني
يعني خد يعني ده اقتصاد اردوغان يعني
الاسباب سياسيه برضو هو طبعا ما جابش
النظريه التوت اللي ما جابهاش من فراغ هي
نظريه موجوده لبعض الاقتصاديين ولكنها
محدوده جدا على خلاف جمهور الاقتصاديه
سبب تاني طبعا انه زي كتير من السياسيين
زي بايدن دلوقتي انه رافد اي تقشف رافض
سقف دين لانه عدم الانفاق هيكلفه في
صناديق الانتخاب فيفضل المكاسب الحاليه
وارضاء الناس في هذه اللحظه على حساب
على حساب النتائج على المدى البعيد وبما
ان هو فاز سوف يواجه هذه النتائج على
المدى البعيد
هل يمكن ان ينجح الاتفاق السياسي في
الصومال وتخدع المناطق الفيدراليه لحكم
مركزي والله يا محمد القصه دي عاوزه دراسه
انا لم اتابع الشان في الصومال يعني في
الشهور الاخيره عشان اكون صادق معاك لكن
يعني وبالتالي ما اقدرش ادي لك اجابه يعني
بنعم او لا احنا ما عندناش تجارب نجحت قوي
في الصومال نجحت بشكل معقول انما ما
عندناش هناش يعني نقول ان الصومال رجعت
كما كانت مثلا في الثمانينات مثلا
مسح الرساله انا حاسس ان الصوره وحشه يا
ماندو ولا الصوره كويسه الصوره كويسه
استاذ سيد هل مشروع المشروع الاوسط الجديد
نجح في المنظور الامريكي ام لا ما هو
مشروع الاوسط الجديد معلش سامحني مش عارف
يعني المشروع ده يعني يعني من سنه خمسه
وتسعين بيتداولوا بس يقصد به حاجات كتيره
يعني اذا كنت تقصد فكره انه اسرائيل تبقى
في قلب هذا فقد نجح الى حد كبير ده لو انت
تقصده قل لي انت تقصد ايه وانا تحت امرك
لماذا لا تعلن السلطه الفلسطينيه الانسحاب
من اتفاقيه اسطو لعدم تنفيذ اسرائيل لعدم
تنفيذ اسرائيل بنودها لان السلطه عاوزه
تفضل موجوده في السلطه يا اخونا واذا هم
خرجوا من اصله واذا هم
يعني عبروا عن رفضهم واذا راحوا للامم
المتحده واذا حاجات كتيره يتحولوا الى
جماعه معارضه وبالتالي
يعني مش قادرين يواجهوا الناس بالحقيقه
مفيش حاجه تتعمل يعني هم يدركوا تماما انه
لا يوجد اي امل في التفاوض مع
الاسرائيليين لانه ما يطلبه الاسرائيليون
لا يمكن ان يسمح بقيام دوله ومعظم
السياسيين الفلسطينيين موجودين في مناصبهم
لانهم بيتفاوضوا على قيد دوله اذا صرحوا
الناس بالحقيقه هيكون مكانهم ما حملت
السلاح مع جماعته المقاومه وهم يعني ده مش
هو اللي ياملوه يعني انما طول ما هم
بيقولوا نحن نامل نطلب نحن ننتظر نحن نطلب
من المجتمع الدولي انا لا ادنهم يعني انا
بقول لك انا تشخيصي كده انا تشخيصي للازمه
كلها على بعض كده ان اسرائيل لا تستطيع
تقديم السلام لانه ده ينتزع منها صلاحيات
كثيره جدا وفلسطين لا تستطيع الحرب لان
طبعا هي ما تقدرش تحارب اسرائيل لوحدها
ولكن هي كانت المفروض تبقى مدعومه من دول
اخرى والدول الاخرى للعربيه كلها نفضت
يدها بشكل كبير وكل الادوار اللي بتقوم
بها الدول العربيه في ادوار وساطه لان
الفلسطينيه لم تعد قضيه مركزيه لهذه الدول
لاسباب كثيره تحدثنا عنها قبل ذلك
بالتالي ردا على سؤالك لو السلطه عملت
اللي انت بتقول عليه لم تبقى في مقاعدها
ما تنساش ان ما فيش انتخابات من سنه 2009
يعني المفروض
الانتخابات للرئيس محمود مازن مفيش
انتخابات وبالمناسبه المقاومه كمان يعني
مستفيده من
من من المقاومه احيانا بدون مقاومه يعني
سؤال اخر من طباعك عن قمه السبعه الجي سفن
وقمه الصين واسيا الوسطى
فالقمم لم تكن اقتصاديه بل سياسيه بحته هل
تعتقد انها خارطه تحالفات ما قبل الحرب
الحرب العفاسه اعتقد ان الخريطه التحالفات
قبل الحرب العالميه الثالثه دي بقى قصه
تانيه
بالنسبه لقمه
كان يعني باستثناء الامور اللي تخص هذه
الدول في البايلاتر او في العلاقات فيما
بينها هو الاصرار لغايه اخذ النفس في
لغايه اخر نفس في دعم اوكرانيا
مهما تطلب الامر هذا يعني ان الحرب سوف
تظل مستمره واعتقد انه الولايات المتحده
بتلعب دور رئيسي باعتبارها الدوله العامه
في هذا
المنظمه واعتقد انه فيها للموضوع ده عده
اسباب واحد منهم لانه الاسباب كثيره انه
لا يبدو من المنطقي ابدا دلوقتي ان الرئيس
بايدن
يقر مثلا بمفاوضات يلجا لمفاوضات او يوقف
الحرب او يوقف الدعم لانه هو دخل على
انتخابات اذا اوقفت الحرب الناس يسالك انت
اوقفتها طب انت حققت الاهداف اذا دخل على
مفاوضات لا ينكر المفاوضات دي تنتهي بشكل
يرضي الولايات المتحده ولا يرضي وبالتالي
هو مضطر انه يبقى على الازمه
لاطول فتره ممكنه الى ان تنتهي الانتخابات
بفوز او بخسارته يعني بالنسبه لقمه
بالنسبه للدول اسيا الوسطى كلها دي منطقه
مهمه انا يعني
خلاني ما اتكلمش عليها اني اعتقدت ان هي
خارج النطاق طاقه كثير من المتابعين يعني
انما ممكن سؤالك يشجعني انه يقول لك
بمنطقه اسيا الوسطى لو لو فتحت على
الخريطه هتلاقي ان الاهتمام بالمنطقه ديت
ان دي واحده من مناطق الحيويه جدا لروسيا
وللصين بالنسبه للصين هين هي مر لطريق
الحرير
منه الى من الصين اسيا الوسطى لاوروبا
فيها احد الحرير وكمان
تقرارها وهو استقرار للصحيص وبالنسبه
لانها كانت كانت منطقه
معناها اضعاف
هو الصوره بتروح وبتيجي
لا ما ظبطتش الصوره ضلمه
اوكي
انا بالنسبه لي ظهري لي الصوره
مذبذبه جدا وضعيفه فمش عارف انا المشكله
عندي انا ولا هي عند الناس
وريني كده
مش وحشه
طيب تمام
انت ممكن يكون هنا في حاجه بس استاذنك لو
بستاكد عليها
تحدث عن فوائد التقارب بين ايران ومصر ده
انا بتحدث عنها من طويله انا بقول يعني
انه اصل انا لما كنت دايما بسال ايه يعني
ايه المشكله بين مصر وايران بس انا اتكلمت
الحلقه اللي فاتت فمش حابب ان انا اعيد
تاني هو التقارب دايما بين دولتين هيكون
معناها ان البلدين ممكن يتعاونوا لفائده
كليهما ولفائده الدول الاخرى لانه اكيد
فوائد السلام والاستقرار احسن من فوائد
الحرب يعني او القطيع يعني
انما كانوا دائما بيقولوا انه والله في
اصل في مشاكل انه ايران ان مصر عندها
تحفظات على تقارب مع ايران لان عندهم
وعناصر امنيه لانه
[موسيقى]
يعني عندهم تحفظات بيقولوها واحد اتنين
تلاته انا اتكلمت عنها في الحلقه اللي
فاتت مش عاوز اوكررها تاني انما بقول
دايما ان ما فيش بلدين يعني العلاقه بينهم
علاقه عظيمه قوي يعني هي العلاقه بين
اسرائيل وامريكا علاقه عظيمه جدا مش ما
فيش بينهم اختلافات خالص العلاقه بين
الروس والصين علاقه عظيمه جدا
في عيد ميلاده الميه واحتفل بعيد ميلاده
الميه في 27 مايو وبعدين راحوا قبلوه
مجموعه من الصحفيين من
وبيسالوه عن الصين وروسيا انا ما اقدرش
اتخيل انه ممكن يبقى هم حلفاء ناتشورال
تلقائيين هم بيجمعهم العداء الامريكي بس
وبيقول يعني انا عمري ما قابلت مسئول روسي
واتكلم بشكل كويس عن الصين في السر ولا
مسؤول صيني اتكلم كويس عن روسيا ومع ذلك
علاقتهم قويه جدا فمش حاجه غريبه قوي انه
تبقى فيه علاقات وفي تناقضات طالما مش
تناقضات جوهرهم وتبقى العلاقات جيده دول
الخليج
والدول العربيه اذا قامت علاقات جيده مع
تركيا ومع ايران الفوائد هتكون كبيره مع
التسليم ان هناك خلافات زكاتره خلافات لا
يمكن تحملها يا اما مش ممكن بلد زي
البحرين يكون في توجه في ايران بيقول ان
انت جزء منه مثلا وده مش وارد يعني ولكن
دي احيانا بتبقى ناس كده منفلته في
الجرايد الايرانيه ويقول لك خلاص اعمل معي
علاقه ودلوقتي انت ما عندكش علاقات ايران
ما عندهاش علاقات الا مع ثلاث دول المغرب
والبحرين ومصر
نامل ان هم يتجاوزوا خلافتهم وفي مفاوضات
على الاقل ما بين البحرين ومصر وايران مش
عارف اذا كانت في مفاوضات جاده بينها وبين
المغرب ولا لا محتاجه مراجعه يعني
لماذا توقفت محادثات السلام بين الحوثيين
والسعوديه معرفش يا محمد ان المحادثات
توفقت بس انا عارف انه السعوديه
وبالمناسبه حكايه انه بقت في حل مشكله
خزان صافر معناها ان واحد من
علامات التهدئه مشكله في اليمن انه اللي
تقدر تعمله السعوديه مع الحوثيين هي
التهدئه فيما يتعلق بها هي على حدود ها هي
مشاكلها هي لكن ما فيش مفاوضات ممكن
تتعامل مع الحوثيين
تؤدي الى انه الحوثي مثلا يتفاهم مع القوى
الاخرى ويسلمهم السلطه طائعه او يشاركها
مع اخرين مفيش
مفيش حاجه لا سعوديه ولا غير سعوديه لان
كمان السعوديه دول الخليج الاخرى موقفها
مش موقف مش موقف سلطنه عمان ولا موقف
الامارات
ولا موقع يعني ما هماش على قلب رجل واحد
يعني وانا بتكلم على دول الخليج باعتبرهم
ان هم اصحاب الكلمه الاكبر فيما يتعلق
باليمن
توجهات كتيره في اليمن فاللي تقدر تعمله
السعوديه انها توصل لاتفاقات تهدئه مع
الحوثي فتنجوا بنفسها لكن تفتكر انا مش
يعني اسف لا اعتقد ان هي عندها القدره ان
هي تدير عمليه سلام ووئام بين الاطراف
بحيث ان هي تبقى صانع سلام بين كل الاطراف
دي التناقضات بين الاطراف الداخليه في
اليمن اكبر بكثير وتوازن القوى مختل بحيث
ان انت صعب ان انت تقعدهم على مائده
المفاوضات فيتنازل الحوثي لهؤلاء الفرقاء
ويعطيهم امتيازات فشلوا في ان ياخذوها
بالقوه العسكريه
وما فيش يعني برضو مش من مصلحه كل الدول
الوضع في اليمن يستتب وتبقى في قوه مركزيه
واحده فضلا عن بعض اليمنيين رافضين ده
اصلا يعني
جوده الصوره سيئه جدا معالي اهو تاني
انا مسلم سلفي المعتقد احمد موافق طيب
استاذ احمد ربنا يوفقك او حاجه يعني لما
تكون سلف المعتقد على حسب تعريفك للسلفيه
لكن اهلا وسهلا الاسئله كثيره حسام حاج اه
فهمت يعني حسام بيقول امنع الاسئله يعني
نكتفي بهذا القدر انت وقفت الاسئله
احنا اخونا حسام انا بجاوب الى ان يعني
اشعر ان الوقت تجاوزنا وبعد كده ان شاء
الله بنكمل في حلقات احنا ان شاء الله اذا
ربنا يعني كان في العمر بقيه احنا نلتقي
اسبوعيا بنجرب فتره فكره المباشر الاسبوعي
دوت واذا نجحت هنخليها كل اسبوع باذن الله
هل الحرب بين حزب الله واسرائيل مساله
وقته طول عمرها مساله وقت طول عمرها مساله
وقت طول ما في اضطرابات وانه في تناقضات
واضحه حزب قائم اصلا على مقاومه اسرائيل
واسرائيل ولا يعترف بها فيما انه اسرائيل
لا يمكن تطمئن ابدا لوجود اي قوه اذا كانت
ميل الشاويه او دوله لازم تكون مساله وقت
بمجرد ما يختل موازين القوه بمجرد ما تحصل
اضطرابات هتبقى فيه صراعه بس الاثنين في
ميزان ردع مش ميزان قوه يعني لان الفرق ما
بين اسرائيل وحزب الله طبعا مهوله لكن في
موازين ردع انه اسرائيل تستطيع تدمير
لبنان كله لا قدر الله انما يستطيع حزب
الله ان يلحق بها اضرارا يرضعها عن ذلك
وانا بعتقد انه 2006 كانت انتصارا لحزب
الله يعني
ما هي اسباب التخلف في العالم العربي
الاسلامي وما هي ما هو طريق الحل ده سؤال
كبير قوي يا احمد انما انا طبعا يعني ما
اعتقدش ان انا الشخص المؤهل للاجابه على
هذه السؤال الكبير الضخم جدا ولكن هنفضل
نقول انه طالما احنا لا نحترم العقل
وبنعتبر انه العقل يعني
[موسيقى]
شيء التفكير الشيء يجب ان نستغفر الله منه
صعب ان انت تتقدم انت محتاج تفكر بحريه من
غير ما تكون مقيد من المؤسسات الدينيه
الاسلاميه والمسيحيه والدوله انت لما
بتتكلم في عمل على نقاب النقابه بتقاضيك
تقول لك فين صوره المحامي فين صوره مش
عارف الصحفي فين صوره الجيش كل المؤسسات
بقت تبوس لا تستطيع ان تتحدث عن الجيش ولا
عن الشرطه ولا عن القضاء ولا على مؤسسه
الدينيه المسيحيه والاسلاميه نستطيع ان
تكتب عن شيء طبعا ده بيختلف من دوله
المحاذير كثيره قوي والدوله اللي ما فيهاش
محاذير ببساطه لان الدوله منهاره زي الدول
اللي هي
يعني ما فيش فيها دوله تقريبا يعني او
فيها دوله بعده رؤوس زي ما الوضع انتم
شايفين كده في
لبنان واليمن الى اخره
تمام
هل ما هي اسباب التخلف استاذ سيد اريد ان
اصحح لك فكره قلتها ان انه ليس جميع
السوريين مع الثوره والا كان سقط النظام
كان اكثر من 90% ضده النظام ولكننا في
سوريا لا نستطيع التحدث بالامر حتى مع
زوجاتنا خلف الابواب المغلقه
تمام يعني انا احيانا انا مش قادره
بالعديد سامحني انا انت بتتكلم لو اكثر من
90% صعب ان تسعين الا اذا كان التسعين في
المئه خامرين يعني هو المنطق بيقول انه
النظام بشار الاسد مهواش يعني اكثر جبروته
بالنظام من نظم كثيره سقطت يعني في
رومانيا في ايران احنا نتكلم عن نظمكم على
تجارب بعيد عننا ليه مكان نظام الشاه
المدعوم من الولايات المتحده والمدعومه من
اسرائيل ومدعوم من الغرب وعنده مخابرات
يعني كل دول لما عدد كبير قوه حركه تحركت
سقطت وبالتالي فانت لكن عموما اوكي انا
فاهم من كلامك احنا ما عندناش احصاءات
والتفكير العلمي يقول هات احصاء مفيش
احصاء ولكن
النظام كان عنده عدد معقول من المؤيدين او
عدد معقول من غير الراغبين في التحرك فقوه
سلبيه بالاضافه فعلا انه الدول اللي تحركت
الى نجدته يعني بذلت الغالي والرخيص ما
انت ممكن العالم كله يكون بايدك نظريا لكن
لا يتحرك يعني يقول لك كلام كده لطيف
وخلاص انما روسيا وايران جم
بقدهم وقديدهم وباموالهم ورجالهم وبالتالي
دي كانت قوه ما هياش قليله يعني بالاضافه
الى العدد اللي احنا مختلفين عليه عشره
عشرين ثلاثين خمسين انت بتقول اكتر اقل من
10% ماشي
امين بيقول السلام عليكم اشتقنا لك استاذ
سيد ربنا يخليك امين ما مستقبل كمال
والمعارضه في تركيا بعد خساره الانتخابات
باي باي كمان هو قال كده اردو باي باي
كمان لا كل شيدر اوغلو 74 سنه
هيحظى اولا معواز التغيير يعني مش بعد
يعني بعد خمس سنوات تسعه وسبعين سنه ما
اعتقدش بتركيبته ممكن ان يكون موجود على
الساحه السياسيه ليقود حزبه الحاجه
التانيه انه مش بس سنه هو كمان كان متهم
من داخل المعارضه بانه اضعف فرسهم في
الفوز بانه لو كان ترك هذا الامر ليه
معارضين اخرين زي امام اوغلو مثلا لكان
الامر افضل اللي هو حاكم اسطنبول
فالمعارضه يعني
في الغالب الحزب العداله والتنميه الرئيس
اردوغان سوف يقسو عليها في الفتره القادمه
في الغالب يعني لانه
هي
هو يعني الحزب بطبيعته هيلعب على نقاط
الضعف في المعارضه ونقاط الضعف كثيره
الراجل منتشي بانتصاره
خساره المعارضه قد تفككها
وبالتالي
يعني واذا نجح اردوغان في حل مشاكل
الاقتصاد اسهموا اسهم حزبه سوف تتضاعف
كثيرا يعني اما اذا سال اقتصاد فما فيش
حاجه ابدا ممكن توقف
البطون الجائعه يعني
مساء الخير زعلان عليك لانك قلت ان
السعوديه قتلت خاشقجي المعارض رغم انه
تصرف فردي من الاشخاص تم محاكدهم بشكل
علني اين الحياه اين الحياه يا اخونا ده
هو السعوديه اللي قالت كده انا اللي قلت
السعوديه قالت نعم هذا خطا واعتذر عنه ولي
العهد قال انا لم اعطي امرا انما في
مؤسسات
تورطت في هذا يعني ده مش خطا يعني معقوله
يعني معقوله مجموعه من ظباط الشرطه ولا
ظباط المخابرات فكروا يروحوا يجيبوا
يقتلوه لا الخطا واضح هذه عمليه لا يمكن
ابدا غير ان هي لم تكن عمليه كفء لا يمكن
ان تكون تمت كده على مستوى مثلا
مستوى القيادات الوسطى الخلاف كله وبين كل
القيادات الكبيره وهو دور ولي العهد ولي
العهد قال انا لم اكن اعلم خلاص لم يكن
اعلم والدول بتقول خلاص نعتبر انه ولي
العهد خارج هذه القصه ودي كانت مساله
بالغه الحساسيه وبالتالي هم ركزوا على ان
بعد القيادات التنفيذيه عمل الدفع
السعوديه قالت انا اخطات وهذا الخطا يجب
ان نتداركه وقالت كده انه السعوديين قالوا
ان هذا لم يكن له علاقه بس مش قالوا
السعوديه يعني
ومع ذلك يعني هذا هو المعلومات اللي
موجوده انا ما اعرفش هل السعوديه قدمت
روايه مختلفه هي حاكمه الناس يعني حاكمه
الناس يعني الناس كان عندهم اخطاء وتمت
اقاله شخصيات الى اخره
دي معلوماتي اذا كان في معلومات اخرى
اي اطراف اي اطراف الصراع في اوكرانيا
اكثر رغبه في وقف الحرب لا ما اعرفش ان في
الا اذا كان الناس العاديه ما فيش اطراف
في اوكرانيا اطراف النافذه تريد وقف الحرب
لان الحرب
بتغذي اكثر العناصر التشددا كل اللي
اتقتلوا حد وكل بيت وكل وقف عمله وكل
المهجر يكون عنده رغبه او عدد كبير منهم
في ان الحرب تستمر
انتقاما لما حدث يعني نفس الوضع بقى الوضع
القوميين في روسيا وفي موضوع في روسيا
عاوز يتوقع يتوقف عنده لانه واضح ان فيه
تطورات خطيره في الحرب انا كان موضوع
كنت اعتقد انه هيكون الموضوع الرئيس لكن
اسئلتكم جراثنا الى اخرى ان شاء الله نخصص
له حلقه بما انه لم يحظى باهتماماتكم
يعني تطور الحرب في العمق الروسي تطور
خطير جدا عاوز مراقبه وعاوز تحليل
الامر الثاني الرد الروسي اذا ظل غير قادر
على رضع المساله ديت حاجه من الاتنين اما
هيغري الاوكران او العناصر المدعومه من
اوكرانيا والغرب بالهجوم اكثر واحراج
الرئيس الروسي اكتر او انه هيورط
الروس في رد فعل
بالغ العنف من اجل منع هذه الهجمات وفي
حالتين هينتج عنها تغيرات كبيره في تطور
تاني على المستوى الحرب وهو
[موسيقى]
يفجيني
بروجزيني اللي هو
اتمنى يكون الاسم اللي هو رئيس
رئيس جماعه واجنر او شركه واجنر كل يوم
خطاب الناقد للقيادات الجيش واللي وزير
الدفاع ثم للاداء المؤسسه العسكريه كلها
ثم للهدف مؤخرا من الحرب وان الحرب فشلت
في تحقيق اهدافها يضع الف علامه استفهام
على مغزى هذه الانتقادات اللي صعب جدا انه
يتم تقبلها ويضع علامات استفهام هو ايه
الهدف من هذه الانتقادات ولكن انتم ما
سالتوش عنها فنخليها ان شاء الله لما يكون
عندنا حلقه نطرحها عشان ما افرضش عليكم
شيء انتم ما طلبتوهوش يعني
ردا على سؤالك معظم القوى اللي مسيطره على
القرار الاوكراني لا تريد وقف الحرب كما
يتبين لي لماذا لا تستضيف خبير يشرح لنا
سبل مواجهه شرح المياه العذبه وعلى راسها
الزراعه بالماء البحر والله ممكن يا استاذ
نصراوي يعني موضوع لطيف لا لا
نقطع تاني لا اسود اهو والله اسود
وبعدين يا جماعه
انا بس ببقى يعني مساله الضيوف
خلاص ماشي حاضر انا بدل ما ادخلك في
تفاصيل قد يعني تكون ممله بالنسبه لحضرتك
لكن حاضر يعني ممكن نفكر في قضيه حروب
الميادي ما هياش قصره بس على يعني دول
المنطقه ده شح المياه دي مساله شغل العالم
كله
والمناوشات الاخيره بين افغانستان وايران
كان سببها المياه بالمناسبه يعني في
الفتره الاخيره
هل ستنخفض اسعار النفط اكثر بعد ان زادت
روسيا من انتاجها لدعم سقف السعر المفروض
وهل الغى الغرب بالفعل
وهل الغى الغرب بالفعل ارباح روسيا
الزائده منذ اشهر خلال فرد سقف السعر شوف
بالنسبه للجزء الثاني اقدر اقول عليه انه
طبعا تاثرت روسيا بشكل كبير بالعقوبات
اللي موجوده ده ليس سرا الجزء الاولاني
يتعلق بالتنبؤ بمثار سعر البترول لا اعلم
ده عاوز حد يكون خبير بتاع الاسعار بترول
فلا استطيع ان افتيك مساء الخير سيد سيد
هل سيتغير برايك موقف اردوغان من اللاجئين
السوريين في ظل فوزيه وتراجع مقاعد تحالفه
تراجع مقاعد تحالفه
يعني انت تراجع نسبي يعني لكن هو اخذ
الاغلبيه يعني مش جايب ال 300 حاجه وستين
اللي بتدي له اغلبيه مطلقه بس جايب
321 او 322 فعنده عنده اغلب مريحه يعني
هل يتراجع موقف وانا اظن انه موقوف المعلن
هو اللي هيعمله هو قال ايه في الاخر انه
هيرجع اللي اعلنه هو اللي يناسبه انا مش
هاخد موقف دراماتيك الديكور كل اليد سوف
لا هو بيقطع كل حاجه
هو هيعيد هيشجع على اعاده اكبر عدد ممكن
من اللاجئين انما لن يكون هذه العوده اذا
ظلت الامور على هذا النحو بالمعطيات ديت
زي ما كانت المعارضه اللي حاولت المغالاه
كثيرا بطرد الناس يعني هو لكن قطعا يقينا
هيحاول ارضاء برضو عدد كبير من
الاكراد بعدم استقبال المزيد من اللاجئين
بالتوقف عن سياسه الابواب المفتوحه
للتبعها لعده سنوات للسوريين والافغان
وغيرهم ثم سوف يبدا لانه كمان دي مش بس
مساله مرتبطه بغضب الاكراد دي مرتبطه
بمخططه اللي كان بيحلم بيه انه يستولي على
شمال سوريا او يجعلها منطقه نفوذ لي من
خلال توطين مجموعه من اللاجئين اللي
موجودين اللي مش هيكونوا يعني
قوه يعني مرحبه بالاندماج تحت سلطه النظام
اللي موجود وبالمره طبعا ده تكون انه
يحاول يضغط او يزيح القوى الكرديه اللي
موجوده في شمال سوريا فهي برده اللاجئين
جزء من مخطط كبير عنده خلاصته انه يبسط
نفوذه على شمال سوريا وبدا يحقق دوت وفي
نفس الوقت يضعف نفوت الجامعات الكرديه
اللي موجوده
انما انما هيظل وضع اللاجئين تحت سلطته
على الاقل بالمعطيات الحاليه افضل مما كان
سوف يكون عليه لو جاءت المعارضه
انا احمد حماد الصاوي لماذا قلنا دي اه
معلش اجلنا على هذا السؤال
كيف نجا النظام ام المجتمع الدولي بعد
المجزره التي ارتكبها في حماه 1982 وراحت
حياتها اكثر خمسين الف يعني كيف كيف نجا
النظام امام المجتمع الدولي يعني
المذابح اللي انت بتشير اليها ضد جماعات
ومنها جماعات اسلاميه في
حاله سنه 82 وفي مدينه اخرى بحوالي تذكرها
وحمص يمكن
تم ارتك تم تسال السؤال طيب وهو ازاي نجا
صدام حسين مثلا من اللي حصل في
اواخر التمرينات 89 ضد الكرد على سبيل
المثال طيب ازاي نجت نظم اخرى ارتكبت
مدابح في مختلف دول العالم لا يعني الدول
العالم بتحكم هي مصالحها انا يعني كور ان
في مذبحه ارتكب هنا او ترتكب هناك ناس
بتتكلم كتير تدين انما هو في النهايه نشوف
مصالحه مع بقاء النظام مع زوال النظام طب
لو كانت مصلحته مع زوال النظام هل يستطيع
الاطاحه بهذا النظام واذا اطح بهذا النظام
هل البديل هيكون فوده تضر بالمصالحي هل
البديل هيجي النظام يصعب التفاوض معه مين
الاعتبارات اللي بتحكم قرارات الدول
الاخرى طب هل لو كان في مصلحتي انا قادر
عليها ممكن ده يكون في مصلحتي انا امريكا
انما الدول الاخرى ترفض تماما مثلا او
العكس
مساء الخير حسين
الشريف سؤالي لك كصحفي كيف يمكن للشخص ان
يبني وعي سياسي من خلال الصحف والمجلات
الدوريه بحيث يكونوا على درايه واطلاع
بشكل موضوعي للشان السياسي الدولي والله
سؤال جيد يا استاذ حسين هي عمليه صعبه
بس التيكست تايم انت علشان حضرتك يبقى
عندك اي حد يعني عاوز يبقى عارف اللي
بيقرا وقادر انه ياخد يبقى عنده رؤيه للي
بيحصل
اولا هي عامله زي انت لما بتروح الجيم انت
عاوز النهارده يكون عندك صحه كويسه ويكون
عندك بنيان قوي ما تقدرش ابدا بطريقه سهله
يبقى عندك بنيان قوي وصحي عمليه فيها كتير
من الصبر والاصرار والمعاناه انك تمتنع عن
الجنط بانك بتنتظم في التمرين بانك بتثابر
عليه لايام طويله ولا شهور طويله نفس
القصه بالنسبه للعقل اول حاجه تمتنع عليها
ولا امتنع عن الجنط الحاجات القمامه
الحاجات القمامه ديت يعني الكتابات
والبرامج التي لا قيمه لها بتاخد وقتك
وجهدك وما بتعملش حاجه خالص وفي تقديري ان
معظم برامج التلفزيون ممكن تستفيد منها بس
فائده محدوده وفائده خبريه انك تعرف
الاخبار لكن تبني فكره البرامج عندها توجه
طول ما انت عاوزه تقوله وحتى في هذا
التوجه بتديره بطريقه مشتته جدا تفتح شاشه
التلفزيون بتلاقي مقدم البرنامج ومعه
ضيفين واحيانا ثلاثه واحيانا اربعه
المذيع بيتكلم وبعدين بياخد حاجه من
المراسل ثم الضيوف فترات صغيره عشان يكون
في تنوع وبعدين في استرابات تحت عناوين
سريعه عناوين اخبار تحت واسترابات بتقول
فعمليه مشتته جدا ثم فواصل النتيجه اللي
انت بتقضي فتره طويله جدا دون ان تحصل على
معلومه مركزه وواضحه تساعدك في تكوين وجهه
نظر
انت عاوز تعمل ايه انت محتاج ان انت تختار
القنوات القنوات ديت بمعنى اذا كانت قناه
في التليفزيون على يوتيوب على فيسبوك كتب
جرائد تحاول انت بالوقت هتلاقي الناس اللي
هم بيقدموا لك ماده جيده تنتقيهم وبالخبره
هتلاقي نفسك بتستبعد
بتركز على مصادر محدده وتصبر على المساله
لان المساله هي انت
بتغذي وعك محتاج تقرا اكثر محتاج تسمع
المصادر المحترمه اكتر علشان
تقدر تحقق اللي انت بتعمله على العموم
فيما يتعلق بالجراد والمجلات في حاجه
ثانيه لو تقدر تعملها وان يكون عندك لغه
اجنبيه اذا كان عندك لغه اجنبيه ده
هيساعدك انك توصل لمصادر معلومات متاحه
وسهله بدرجه عمق وعي اكتر بكتير من
المحتوى العربي اللي للاسف الشديد جدا جدا
جدا بالغ السوء بالغ السطحيه
مفيد او سيريس اس ايران افغانستان محدود
لماذا لم تقم حتى شركات النفط الامريكيه
بزياده انتاج النفط اذا كانت الولايات
المتحده قلقا للغايه بشان ارتفاع اسعار
النفط بالنظر الى حقيقه ان الولايات
المتحده المنتج الاول للنفط شركات النفط
بتحركها دوافع الربح الخساره هم عانوا
كثيرا في السنوات الماضيه وبيقولوا انه
انا النهارده علشان ازود الانتاج يعني
هزود الاستثمارات وبيعتقدوا ان الفتره
اللي فاتت ان هو مش محتاج انه انت هتزود
الاستثمارات يعني ايه بدل ما توزع ارباح
على المساهمين هتحتجز الارباح ديت وتزود
الاستثمار واذا عمل ده معناها انه هينتظر
على المدى البعيد انه ياخد عوائده عنده
مشكلتين مشكله الاولانيه انه حمله الاسهم
بيقولوا احنا عاوزين ارباحنا دلوقتي لان
احنا خسرنا كتير الحاجه التانيه ان في
شكوك من كتير من المستثمرين ان الاستثمار
في البترول والغاز قد لا يكون مجدي على
مدى خمس وعشر سنوات لانه بيعتقده انه
هتكون المصادر الطاقه البديله حلت محلها
وبالتالي غير مراقبين في ان هم يتورطوا في
استثمارات طويله الامد
والدوله ما عندهاش قدره زي مثلا دول
الخليج او الجزائر ان هي هي المتحكم
الاساسي الحكومه الامريكيه لا تملك شركات
بترول يعني ولكن كلهم قطاع خاص وكتاب خاص
حقيقي
يصعب على الدوله الا بالقانون ان هي تتحكم
في مساره او في قراراته
ما مستقبل
نفوذ وتوسع ايران في الدول العربيه مرتبط
يا استاذ محمد العتيبي بضعف الدول العربيه
الايران نفوذها في الدول العربيه زي نفوس
تركيا زي نفوس اسرائيل زي نفوس روسيا زي
نفوس اي دوله اخرى مرتبط بضعف الدول
العربيه كل مكان توازن كل مكان في الدوله
متماسكه وقويه هيكون صعب ان ايران تخترق
هذه الدوله كل الدوله ما كانت هشه
ومتداعيه في ايران وغير ايران هتنفذ الى
هذه الدوله وتبقى خاطئه لو ما عملتش كده
كل الدول بتعمل كده بيشوف فراغ بيتمدد فيه
سؤال لو سمحت دكتور جبيل انا لست دكتورا
يا صديقي العزيز انا سيد قبيل الصحفي اما
وقد قلت هذا فاهلا وسهلا بسؤالك لو سمحت
ما احتمال لجوء المصريين لحمل السلاح ضد
النظام في حاله تفاقم الازمه الماليه في
حاله استخدم النظام القوه المفرطه لكبه
تلك الثورات عبد اللطيف لاعب عبد اللطيف
عمل سيناريو دموي في ازمه اقتصاديه
والازمه الاقتصاديه نامل ان هي تنفرج اذا
ساءت الازمه مش بالضروره لازم تكون الشكل
دموي ده انت افتكر احنا خلينا في التاريخ
القريب ده كان عندك ثورات الربيع العربي
الناس صارت وكل اللي حصل ان هي ثوره تكاد
تكون يعني
تعتبر بالنسبه بمعيار اي ثوره
يعني انت قلت انا مش قادر الوضع صعب اني
استقره وخلاص خصوصا ان في انتخابات في
2024 ففكره انه الناس تحمل السلاح والدوله
تحمل السلاح يعني مش مالوف في مصر مصر
يعني ثورتها
واعتراضاتها بتكون اقل عنفا بكثير من دول
اخرى يعني
هل هناك قلق على اموال المودعين في البنات
المصريه اقصد بالعملات الاجنبيه
معرفش ان حصل ان حد حتى هذه اللحظه ان حد
كان مودع باموال
قالوا له ما عندناش فلوس ليك انما
الشركات المستثمره اللي هي الشركات
الاجنبيه وجدت صعوبه في بعض الفترات في
تحويل ارباحها بالدولار لفتره انما تروح
تقول له انا عندي فلوس ما عنديش لم اسمع
بها من قبل وعموما انا مش الشخص المناسب
اللي ممكن يقول لك انه
انا ما اعتقدش ان في سر يعني اعتقد هو ده
اللي موجود
اذا كنت بتكلمني على حاجه انا ما اعرفهاش
يعني
معلش لحظه الاسئله ظهرت كده
وما شاء الله اسئله كتير قوي يا ممدوح
انا كده رجعنا الاول تاني
[موسيقى]
ده انا كده معلش يا شباب حاضر
حد بيقول البث بيقطع يا جماعه مندو موجود
فتتوقعوش كتير
بس كده انا شايف الصوره حلوه انت عملت ايه
يعني بعد ساعه ونص ظبطت
[موسيقى]
انا اسف ان انا هرجع للاسئله الاول بس
هحاول ارجع تاني يعني في اسئله جدت كتير
انا من فلسطين ارى ان حل الدولتين انتهى
ما طبعا يا محمد حل دولتين تقريبا انتهى
طبعا
عبد الرحمن مصطفى هل تعتقد ان اردوغان
سيذهب بعد نهايه الخمس سنوات حيث ان هذه
هي اخر فتره له وفقا للدستور والله هو حصل
ان الدستور اتغير قبل كده الراجل عمره
69 تقريبا بعد خمس سنوات ممكن يكون اربعه
وسبعين يعني قد المرشح كمان كل شينار
اوغلو ما تندهش ابدا ابدا
انه يتم انه
السيناريو الاقرب للمنطق انه يعهد الى
السلطه باحد زي ما عمل كده بوتين يعني
لاحد الناس المقربين اليه ويبقى امتداد
ليه زي ما حصل يلدز مثلا عاهد الى السلطه
او انه ما هياش حاجه مستحيله يحصل تغيير
في الدستور دول كتير عملت تغيير في
الدستور ومنها تركيا في 2017
هل امتلكت السعوديه رؤوس النوويه من
باكستان مستحيل ده يحصل يا صديقي يعني دون
ان يظل سرا يعني ولم يحدث في التاريخ ان
في دوله نوويه اهدت لدوله اخرى رؤوس
النوويه
معك داوود امير نتمنى لك الصحه والعافيه
لو كان هناك شاشه اكبر علشان ظهرك وعيونك
ربنا يخليك ويحفظك والله يا اخونا داود
شكرا جزيلا والله لمسه رقيقه منك يعني كثر
خيرك هات لنا شاشه
وش دي العنصريه ما تختارون غير اسئله
المصريين رسلت لك سؤالي مليون مره والله
العظيم ما اعرف ده مصري ولا باكستاني ولا
امريكي اطلاقا ولا بتجاوز سؤال واحد يا
ابراهيم خالص انا بمشي بالترتيب ولما
بيحصل الترتيب يختل بيكون نتيجه انه
الاسئله جريت فبرجع تاني واعيدها كلها
تاني من الاول
وبالمناسبه انا افاجئ بالسؤال وانا اقراه
عيني ما بتجيبش اللي بعده فممكن اجد سؤال
يعني
زي ما بيطلع السؤال يعني بس قل لي ايه هو
يا ابراهيم
ما تاثير الدعم ده زعلان قوي ابراهيم
اكتبوا دلوقتي يا اخونا ولو ماندو شافوا
اه والله والنبي الله يخليك يا ابراهيم
زعلان قوي ده حاطط لي علامات غاضبه جدا
ما تاثير الدعم السعودي الاماراتي
للاقتصاد التركي على الانتخابات الاخيره
هو من اقتصاد التركي كان يعني حصلت
مساعدات لكن هل كان لها تاثير الاقتصادي
للانتخابات تمت
والانفليشن او التضخم كان ايضا يعني نسبته
كبيره جدا مليره منخفضه والاسعار مرتفعه
يعني ما اقدرش احدد قد ايه
لكن هو مش بقى الدعم الخليجي انما هي
سياسه اردوغان بان هو يهدئ بعدها للخليج
ويهدئ مع مصر ويهدئ مع اسرائيل ويهدئ مع
عدد من الدول يعني بالاضافه للاسباب اللي
احنا قلناها في حلقه كيف نجح او كيف
استطاع ان يفوز على الانتخابات يعني نحول
الدفه اساسا قلل الاتراك اقنعهم ان دي مش
مساله
اقتصاد خالص زي مساله هويتكم مساله
مستقبلكم مساله امنكم
اقنع هؤلاء ثم يعني برضو الاسباب التانيه
انه الراجل استطاع انه يجير كل قدرات
الدوله لهذه الانتخابات بصراحه يعني مساء
الخير يا استاذ سيد الحكومه استاذ سيد
الحكومه واللي حابب الحكومه للاسف مش
عايزين يعترفوا باخطائهم الاقتصاديه
الاقتصاد موقفنا الاقتصادي في مصر سيء جدا
جدا ارجوك محتاجين تطرح حلول سريعه عمليه
لعلاج الجنائي الاستاذ دانيال
حاجات الحكومه مش عاوزه حد يطرح لها
الحلول الحلول معروفه ومطروحه بس هل
يقدروا ينفذوها هم عارفين ما عندهم
اقتصاديين وعندهم كل حاجه انك تعرف الحل
شيء وانك تقدر تنفذه شيء او انك راغب في
تنفيذه شيء اخر ومع ذلك ارجع على نعرف
اقتصاد فيها مجموعه من الحلقات بتتكلم على
مصر بشكل مكثف جدا استاذنك يعني ترجع لها
فيها اجابه على سؤال حضرتك والحكومه بتشوف
الحلقات زي ما انا بيقابلني المسؤولين
وبيقولوا لي وغيرنا في ناس احسن مننا
عشرات المرات بيقدموا اتصال وهم عندهم
الحلول هو البنك المركزي ما يعرفش وزاره
الماليه ما تعرفش لكن احيانا بتكون
المشكله ضخمه جدا حلها قد يكون صعب على
الحكومه ان هي تقوم به
يعني انت لما تيجي تقول لهم ان بيعوا كل
الاصول بتاعه الدوله صعب في اصول الدوله
مش عاوزه تبعها واذا باعتها عاوزه تبيعها
بالسعر كويس جدا السعر كويس جدا ده مش
مطروح الان اذا باعتها دلوقتي هتحل
مشكلتها مؤقتا ثم بعد سنه سنتين هي اتباعه
عشان ايه عشان توفر دولار بعد سنه سنتين
مثلا الفندق اللي انت بعته عشان تاخد منه
100 مليون دولار ولا اقل ولا اكتر هتخسر
الدولارات اللي كان بيدخلها لك باعتباره
انه كان مسكن بيستقبل السائحين بالدولار
الشركات اللي كانت منتجه هتبيعها تحصل على
مبلغ لكن هتخسر العائد اللي كان بيجي
نتيجه الصادرات لهذه الشركات او على الاقل
الواردات اللي كانت بتغنيك عن صادرات ما
فيش حلول سهله بما انك انت وقعت في ازمه
الازمه عاوزه علاج بقى يعني
يعني يصعب ان انت تقول واحد اتنين تلاته
لكن اول علاج للحكومه انها تقول ان
المشكله كلها مش في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وان هناك اخطاء ارتكبت وانهم
عازمون على علاج هذه الاخطاء يبقى ما فيش
سلف او ما فيش حاله انكار
لمسؤوليه بعض القرارات اللي اتخزتها
الحكومه وبالتالي يشرعوا في الحل وما زلت
مقتنع ان الوضع مش ماساوي ولا مستحيل يعني
لانه الوضع في مصر صعب وفي اقتصادات تانيه
كثيره افتح الدايره هتلاقي دول كثيره
بتعاني من ازمات مشابهه وبالتالي مصر ممكن
تستفيد من هذه الحاله لان العالم مش هيكون
في حاجه الى كل الدول دي تنهار وتضعف ممكن
يستفيدوا من وضعهم كاقتصاد ماذون ضمن
اقتصادات اخرى ويحاول انه
[موسيقى]
ثم دائما عمليه الاصلاح الاقتصادي بتكون
فيها
اجراءات قاسيه كل الحكومات بتتردد في
اتخاذ الاجراءات القاسيه ديت لانها تخشى
طبعا من الاضطرابات الاجتماعيه التي قد
تنجم عنها
مساء الخير هل نقترب من حرب بين اسرائيل
ومحمر محور المقاومه خصوصا مع تاكل الرضع
الاسرائيلي والوضع
تيجي في الاقليم
احنا طول الوقت مغتربين من حرب يعني طول
الوقت على مدار السنوات كان يمكن ان تندلع
حرب بين ايران وبين اسرائيل بصراحه ما انت
تتكلم مين
الحرب هتبقى حرب اذا دخلت ايران ضد
اسرائيل لا اسرائيل قادره على هذا ولا
راغبه فيه ولا ايران قادره ولا راغبه ولا
الولايات المتحده طبعا الحرب هتيجي يبقى
قرار من احد الطرفين يعني لم يحدث حتى هذه
اللحظه
هل امتلكت السعوديه اجابنا انا من فلسطين
اجبنا هل من الممكن الحديث عن التجربه
البلجيكيه الهولنديه مع التضخم لا اعلمها
لكن اوعدك يعني يعني اسال عنها يعني انا
ما اعرفش ان في تجربه هولنديه بلجيكيه
مميزه للتعامل مع التضخم
اشكرك
هل له بالسلاح هو الدعم الرئيس الاستقراء
الاستمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا لا
المستفيدين من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
على فكره في حلقه استاذنك ممكن ترجع لها
في حلقتين الحلقه الاولانيه الدوافع
الخفيه للولايات المتحده وبريطانيا من
الحرب والامر الثاني لماذا لا يستطيع احد
وقف هذه الحرب حتى بوتن نفسه
ومكتوبه اظن كان الصندل خمس مسارات للحرب
استاذنك ارجع للحلقتين دول علشان تعرف انه
ليه الحرب صعبه وقفها يعني
لكن باختصر شديد انا قلت في اول الحلقه
انه في سبب مباشر صعب نوقف الحرب لانه
الناس هيسالوه طب احنا استفدنا ايه
مستفادنا ايه ما انت امريكا دفعت عشرات
المليارات طيب انت هتوقف الحرب دي يعني
ايه هتوقفها على حالها في الحاله ديت يعني
ان اوكرانيا تم تدميرها وانه اقتطع على
الاقل
20% او 25% من اراضيها لصالح الروز زي ما
هم فيها يبقى احنا عملنا ايه ولا هتوقفها
بمفاوضات هتتفاوض على ايه انه تقنع
البوتين انه من غير حرب تنازل عن الاراضي
اللي انت كنت موجود فيها وما يدخلوش مثلا
الف شمال الاطلسي طب ما احنا بدانا الحرب
دي ليه ودعمناها ليه ما انت كنت ممكن تعرض
هذا العرض على من ناحيه التانيه ممكن يوقف
الحرب على اي اساس يوقف الحرب على اساس
تفاوض التفاوض ده يكون ايه نقولوا له سيب
كل الاراضي اللي انت خدتها في الحرب واللي
انت خسرت فيها عشرات الالاف من القتلى
واللي انت يعني ارهقت الاقتصاد الروسي وتم
عزلك على اساس على عزل روسيا يعني او
محاصره تعمل من قبل الغرب وانه ولا تقول
له ايه ولا تقول له اسوا من كده وتشبه شبه
جزيره القرم اللي هو اعلنها ارض روسيه
بالاضافه الى المقاطعات الاربعه اللي
اعلنها الروسيه ارجع في كلامك هتقوله
يتفاوض على ايه طب الرئيس الاوكراني او اي
قوه اخرى يقولوا ايه الناس احنا هنوقف
الحرب بس هنتعزل عن كل اللي احنا
خدنا الحرب على اساسه لا يعني دي حرب
كانت فكره جهنميه
وكل ما زادت كل ما ابقى في
السنك او
يعني انت خلاص خسرت خسرتها بتكمل يعني
استثمرتي كثيرا في هذه الحرب صعب ان هي
تقف في المدى المنظور يعني
هل هل يرجع البئر هل يرجع البعثه للحكم في
العراق تفتكر عشان في حزب يعني في الاردن
قال ان حزب البعث العراقي فيرجع البعث
العراقي حاجه صعبه يعني ما تاثير الدعم
السعودي الاماراتي للاقتصاد التركي على
الانتخابات الاخيره اجابنا البث غير واضح
ويقطع يعني استقر دلوقتي
اخونا ابراهيم
قال لك وش العنصريه ما تختار من غير اسئله
المصريين
ما هو سال بس وما عرفناش نوصله الممتلكت
اجابنا ايه رايك في اللي حصل في نقابه
المهندسين لا اعلم عنه اي شيء في مصر يعني
والله ما اعرف فعلا
وليد
اتس اوكي ماشي الحال
السلام عليكم خارج الموضوع السؤال خارج
الموضوع قليلا في رايك هل تحليلات الاستاذ
عبد الوهاب المسيري عن فلسطين واليهوديه
تعتبر حتى الان تحليلات ذات الصلاه
وهو شاب غير اراءه في السنوات الاخيره
فصعب ان انا اقول اجابه عامه كده لو
بتتكلم على نقطه معينه ولو اعرف الاجابه
عليها انا تحت امرك بس هو اتكلم كثير
وارائه برده طولت مش تغيرت مع الوقت يعني
كيف ترى تعامل مصر مع ملف سد النهضه
بالنسبه لي انا غير واضح
محمد سامي بيقول الصوره مش واضحه بتقل
اصبحت واضحه مساء الخير استاذ سيد الحكومه
اه خلاص اجبنا الصوره سيئه اجابنا السلام
عليكم استاذ سيد
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد بعيدا عن نظريه
المؤامره لماذا تبدو مصر كلها محاصره
عسكريا واقتصاديا مشاكل على الحدود وحتى
على الحدود البحريه مهدده باطماع الغاز
والله انا مختلف معاه يا محمد ما فيش دوله
مش مهدده قل لي مين الدوله اللي هي العالم
سيبقى في حالها يعني العالم سايب الصين في
حالها العالم سايب
روسيا في حالها العالم سايب الهند في
حالها العالم العالم ده اللي انا قلت عليه
اللي كان في حالهم
يعني مين سايب مين ما حدش سايب حد فدائما
الدوله عامله زي غابه فعلا اي دوله بتعيش
في غابه من المجتمع الدولي وكل دول العالم
ان لم تكن يعني تمكر بها فهي في اطار دفاع
عن مصالحها بتنكر بالدول الاخرى وبالتالي
انت ما تتوقعش ان انت هتنهض لما تطلب من
العالم تايم اوت ان الناس يتوقفوا الاول
والدنيا فرصه محدش يديك فرصه يحدد ده فرصه
لايران مثلا حدد ده فرصه لكوبا ل فنزويلا
لاي دوله يعني ما فيش كل الدول بيتم المقر
بها
وهي بقى وظروفها وقدرتها على ان هي تدير
هذه الصراعات علشان تقدر تقف على رجليها
مصر كان عندها فرصه عظيمه يعني من بعد
[موسيقى]
كده بعد مقتل السادات اخذنا حوالي بتاع 30
سنه واكتر في ظل حكم الرئيس مبارك
ما فيش اي مشاكل كبيره تعرقلك يعني
بوتينسكي بوتين
هل تتوقع مفاوضات قريبا ما اعرفش اعذروها
قريبا ولو زاروها لا اتوقع ان يكون في
مفاوضات مباشره بينسكي ممكن كل واحد
يزورها دي قصه تانيه يعني
هل يترشح الرئيس السيسي الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله وموقفهم مع الدستور
الحالي الذي ينص على عدم تولى الرئيس ثلاث
فترات رئاسيه ما ده زي وضع تركيا لما جاء
في 2017 وقالوا له انت ليك فترتين قال لا
الفتره اللي انا بدات فيها قبل التغيير
الدستوري حاجه احنا هنبدا من جديد يعني في
نفس القصه المفسرين في الدستور قالوا لا
بعد ما تم تعديل الدستور هتبدا فترتين من
بعد تعديل الدستور وبالتالي لا عنده فتره
ثاني
وفقا لهذا التفسير يعني لا هو ما قالش ان
انا اترشح ولا لا لكن اعتقد انه ده اللي
هيحصل يعني سلام استاذ سيد انا معجب
بحلقاتك ممكن تحكي لي عن ازمه الصومال ليه
هي مش مستقره لا دي عاوزه حلقه كامله
الصومال دوله من الدول اللي هي حاله
كلاسيكيه للدول الفاشله نتيجه الحرب
البارده حرب البارده يعني الاتحاد
السوفيتي دعم دوله في الحاله بتاعه
في حاله الصومال كانت اثيوبيا
والولايات المتحده دعمت الصومال
يعني
وكانت في حرب طويله ونتيجه دعم الدولتين
دول دعم القوى الكبرى لطرفي مختلفين ذله
الحرب مشتعله كثيرا بالاضافه الى
الاعتبارات الداخليه يعني
لكن امال عاوزه حلقان عارف ان انا قلت
الكلام ده كثيرا ولكن ما يحدث ان دايما
الاحداث يعني انا ببقى عاوز اتكلم عن
الصومال انا نفسي اتكلم عن اذربيجان انا
نفسي اتكلم على حاجات كثيره كده قضايا
مثيره يعني ليها بريق بس بقت انه الاحداث
مثلا بتتم في السودان فانا مضطر لطبع
متابعه الشان السوداني الحالات بتتم
فيكوسوفو فانا بتابع الشقه فالاحداث بتفرض
نفسها وبتؤجل القضايا المهمه الحلوه اللي
مش ساخنه جدا برضو الصوره مش واضحه
عندك انت
ما تاثير الدعم السعودي اجبنا هل امتلكت
السعوديه اجبنا كيف ترى اجبنا ما تاثير
اجبنا ليس لماذا ليس هناك موقف مصر من
قضيه الصحراء هو خوف من الجزائر ام انظمه
العسكر تسانده بعضها بعضا
يا وليد الموقف المصري من القضيه الصحراء
موقف حدود معلوماتي انه هم بيقولوا احنا
موقفنا زي موقف الامم المتحده وزي الاتحاد
الافريقي ما يعني انه موقف لا يرقه كثيرا
للمغاربه يعني
هل امتلكت السعوديه
هلوب السلاح جابنا السلام عليكم اجابنا
تاريخ الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي طويل
والنظر العامه
لاخونا سوبر
تاريخ الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي طويل
والنظر العامه على هذا الصرع تجعل الناظر
على يقين ان الكف ليست بصالح بصالحنا فعدد
المطبعين بزياده ودول عربيه محوريه دمرت
ما هي استراتيجيه المواجهه الصحيحه مع
العدو
والله دي يعني المشكله مش بقينا
الاستراتيجيه مع العدو ده المشكله انه
اسرائيل لم تعد في ادميات كثير من الدول
على انها عدو وان العدو مره يبقى بقى دوله
عربيه قطر السعوديه على حسب المكان اللي
انت فيه تركيا ايران وما فيش مانع ان انت
يبقى عندك مشكله مع احد جيرانك انما اصبحت
اسرائيل بالنسبه لكثير من دول المنطقه
ليست يعني اولويه اولى
[موسيقى]
بس
كان
علمك ده
كل علمك ده ومش عارف خطوره الشيعه علينا
جميعا انتقدت العثمانيه بمحاربتهم الشيعه
ولا ترى مشكله في الانفتاح عليهم اقرا
وافهم من هم الشيعه وماذا يخططون لنا نحن
السنه رغم اننا لا نعاديها
يعني انا
مش عارف اقول لحضرتك ايه والله
خلاص انا اعذرني انا مش هعرف اعلق يعني
هل امتلكت السعوديه رؤوس نوويه باكستانيه
الاجابه لا
انا انا انا يعني يعني
حاببك بس انا زعلان والله يعني انا كل
الاحترام لك بس انا مش عاوز يعني فكره ان
انت انت ممكن تقول ان في غلام من الشيعه
انت مش مبسوط معهم انما انت بتتكلم على
كل الشيعه خطر يعني اذا كان يعني مثلا
واحده من اهم مؤسسات في كل المؤسسات احدى
زي مؤسسه الازهر كان وما زال المذهب
الشيعي بيدرس فيه وما يضيرك ان الناس
يؤلموا ويتقربوا الله بالمذهب الشيعي ولا
بالمذهب غير الشيعي انت مشكلتك فيه من
يضرك فقط ولا غير كل الشيعه بيتامروا على
كل السنه
وكل السنه لا يعني
تدعميمات انا اسف انها فيها كثير من
التعصب ادعوك ان انت تعيد النظر في هذه
القناعات اللي فيها كتير من التعصب
والشموليه انا بيحزني ان في قنوات بتفرغ
نفسها الليل والغار للهجوم على السنه وعلى
الشيعه انا ما شفتش الهجوم على السنه
وموجود انا كنت بتكلم صديق لي عراقي بقول
له في قناه مش عاوز اقول اسمها ليل ونهار
كل ما قلب هي تيجي قدامي فلاقيه قاعد
بيتكلم كيف ينتقد الفكر مش عارف انت
هتستفيد ايه يعني زي بعض القنوات اللي هي
طول الوقت بتتكلم على مقارنه الاديان
ويثبت ان دين معين خطا وبعد ما اثبته عملت
ايه فانت ما تخليك في دينك واعمل وتقرب
الى الله بدينك وبس يعني فصديق العراقي
قال لي لا انت ما شفتش القنوات السنيه
وعدد لي مجموعه من اسامي القنوات اللي
موجوده في عواصم اوروبيه متفرغه ليل ونهار
في الهجوم على السنه ده عبث بتستفيد بس
بدايه بتاكل عيش انما مش هكذا تمتل الامم
والشعوب سيب اللي عاوز يسلم بيبقى سني ولا
شيعي اترك الملك للمالك وركز انت في دينك
وتقواك واحسن الى الجميع وخلي خلقك هو
دينك يعني
المشكله من اول البث تقريبا وزادت
بالتدريج لكن البث مستقر اعتقد ان هناك من
يهاجم القناه لتناولها موضوعا حساسه الله
اعلم ما مدى خطوره الصراع الايراني اجبنا
انا هستاذنكم ان انا هتوقف خلال خمس دقائق
وبعدين ان شاء الله
نؤجل الاجابه على باقي الاسئله في حلقه
اخرى وبعتذر لو كان النهارده الصوره مش
واضحه جدا يعني
هل تعتقد ان اردوغان سيذهب بعد نهايه
الخمسه اجابنا مساء الخير السيد هل تقترب
من اجابنا قبل مده قصيره كان هناك قادم من
الجيش المصري في عدن مع رئيس المجلس
الانتقالي الجنوبي هل مصر تريد
تزيد من تواجدها في اليمن
لا اعلم بانه كان في وجود قاده عسكريين
وانه ده دلالته ويترتب على ايه عشان ما
اعلقش على حاجه لا افهم فيها اقول الله
اعلم السلام عليكم استاذ سيد بعيدا عن
نظريه المؤامره لماده اجابنا هل لدى
امريكا سلطه على دوله الاحتلال بان تمنع
مخططات نتنياهو عندها السلطه ولكن لا
تمارسها يا تامر هل يقود الوضع في السودان
الى تدخل اممي
يعني الامم تتدخل ازاي تدخل اممي يعني
الدول تبعث قوات لن يبعث احد قوات الى
السودان علشان يغرق في حرب اهليه شك في
ذلك تماما يعني
السيد من هو فليصفك المفضل وما هي فلسفتك
في الحياه لا انا ما عنديش فلسفه في
الحياه اخونا
وجماس يعني فلسفه في الحياه هي بس الافكار
المتواضعه اللي انا بقولها دي اللي انا
بقولها بتبقى يعني دي اجمالي الافكار اللي
انا ارتحت اليها اللي اتربيت عليها اللي
قدرت اطورها مع الوقت لكن فلسفه واحده
معينه لا
انما
الفلاسفه المفضلين عدد كتير من الفلاسفه
سواء كانوا من القدماء او المحدثين احببت
كثيرا يعني ارائهم
وتاثرت بها
بالمناسبه كان في فيلسوف مصري اللي هو
الدكتور زكي نجيب محمود
اللي عنده وقت واللي عنده صبر وهو لغته
بسيطه يعني رجل له افكار
عميقه ومؤثره وممكن يعني يكون
القرايه
تساعدنا في تساعد البعض يعني في تغيير
نظرته في كثير من الامور الحياه عموما انا
خجلان ان انا اخلي الحلقه عامه عما افضل
او لا فاستاذنك حتى لا اشغل الناس
بخصوصياتي لكن انا اشكرك الاهتمامك بشخص
المتواضع يعني
احبك في الله يا استاذ سيد ربنا يخليك هل
تعتقد ان اردوغان سيذهب في نهايه الخمس
سنوات اجابنا يا ريت تخلي البث يومي بدل
من كل اسبوع احمد محمد ربنا يخليك ويكون
معنا ماندو ولا يكون معنا عمرو
استاذ سيد هل تقترب من حرب اجنه ممكن تحكي
لنا عن اجابنا اللي هو مش اجابنا يعني
ارجعنا اجابه السؤال عن الصومال
هل اللي حصل امبارح في اجابنا ما اعرفش
حاجه عن انتخابات المهندسين نقابه
المهندسين في مصر هل تعتقد يا استاذ ان
امريكا تدعم فكره حكم الاقليات في المنطقه
تدعم مصالحها جت مصالحها مع الاغلبيه اهلا
وسهلا مع الاقليه اهلا وسهلا انما كان
الدول اللي هي كانت بريطانيا وفرنسا جت
فتره وجدت انه في دور المشرق العربي ان هي
تمكن تسلح الاقليه بالسلطه وتمكن الاغلبيه
بحكم العدد فيعني مثلا انه العلويين اسره
صغيره تحكم لانها اقليه فتقدر تحمي نفسها
من تغول الاغلبيه عليها
بما ان العراق كان السنه اقليه من حيث
العدد فيحكمه يعني الفكره دي كانت موجوده
كنوع من توازن القوه بين العدد الكبير
مش بالضروره تكون هو ده كان السبب العميق
يعني ورا المساله يعني لكن ده كان واحد من
التبريرات
برايك بالرغم من فوز اردوغان بالانتخابات
لكن لماذا اهم مدام في تركيا واسطنبول
وانقرها كانت اغلبيه الاصوات فيها لكمال
طب وليه تقول كده طب ما تقول ان انت عندك
48 هو ده مش حاجه غريبه يعني في انتخابات
ديمقراطيه بس انا اقدر اقول يعني انه لو
كانت الانتخابات
يعني
مش عارف اقول ايه يعني السعاده السيتينج
الرئيس اللي موجود في السلطه عاده بيكون
له امتيازات
رغم انه
المرشح الرئيسي لم يكن هو المنافس خطير
يعني بحكم تكوينه بحكم انتماءاته رغم ان
المعارضه كانت منقسمه على نفسها رغم ان
اردوغان شخصيه لها تاثير كاريزمي كبير
الانتخابات 48 تقريبا في المعارضه تقول
انه شعبيه اردوغان تراجعت كثيرا
ما هي تطورات الصراع السني الشيعي انا
معرفش ان في صراع سني شيعي بالمعنى حاجه
بتقول عليه الان ولكن في اسرع سن الشيعي
يعني ده ممكن بعض الجماعات
يعني
متشدده هنا وهنا لكن ما فيش صراع سني شيعي
بالمعنى مثلا حرب الثلاثين عاما في اوروبا
في القرن 17
تدهور الحال ليس بسبب الدين يا اخ سيد
بسبب القاده
يخلي علمانيتك لنفسك طب ما انا مخليها
لنفسي والله مش انت سالتني انا جبتها انا
ما قلتلكش حاجه وبعدين اخليها لنفسي ولا
قلت انا صوت واحد ده في ده انت عندك كل
القنوات شغاله ليل ونهار بيقولوا لك حاجه
ثانيه عاوز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه
من الجيد لينا انا من الجيد ليه ان انا
اسمع وجهات نظري مختلفه اذا كنا ملناش
مصلحه ما انا ماليش مصلحه انا عاوز انا
يعني عاوز الفكره اللي انا اشوفها صحيحه
يعني انت حضرتك اسمع السيد اسمع الاراء
المختلفه عنك جايز يعني انا مش هاسلبك
حاجه انا مش ببيع لك فكره ما فيش حاجه لو
انا عملتها لك
يعني هكسب من وراها انا بقول لك فكره انا
مقتنع بها اكون خطا بس من الجيد جدا انك
تتحاور معي ومع غيري بذهن مفتوح ربما يكون
الحوار ده مش حوار طرشان ربما انا اغير
رايي انت تغير رايك وبعدين انا مش واخد
المساله مش يعني مش مساله
يعني مش رساله في الحياه يعني انا انا
بشتغل بتحليل العلاقات الدوليه وبتكلم
اكثر على كذا الفكره ديت فكره انا شايف مش
شايف امل غيرها يعني لو في حد يقول لي
ممكن نعيش مع بعض ازاي بنظام مختلف اهلا
وسهلا بس يعني مش اكتر
انا مش كل يوم بتكلم في الموضوع يعني هل
تعتقد ان اردوغان سوف يقابل بشار الاسد
بيتهيا لي انه ما لهمش حل غير ان هم
يتفاهموا يعني كلاهما في حاجه مثل الاخر
انا اسف انه انا عارف ان في اسئله ما شاء
الله على الضخم جدا انا بس كان نفسي اجاوب
سؤال
اخونا اللي قال العنصريه ابراهيم والله لو
شفته انا بدور عليك علشان ما تقولش في
عنصريه ولا حاجه
فسامحني انا مش شايف اسمك
لكن انا عاوز اقول ان في عدد كبير تاني من
الاسئله كلك ذوق يا سيد ربنا يخليك ممكن
تكلمنا عن توابع الحرب للعمق الروسي وكان
الموضوع الرئيسي لكن الاسئله اخذتنا في
موضوعات اخرى
سامحوني علشان يعني احنا بقى لنا تقريبا
ساعتين بعتذر لكم عن حاجتين الاسئله التي
لم اتمكن من الاجابه عنها ان شاء الله
عندنا موعد الاربعاء القادم فالاسئله التي
لم اتمكن من الاجابه عليها ومره تانيه
والله لم اترك سؤال واحد حتى لما ما
بعرفوش بقولوا بقول انا مش عارفه
فاعذروني على انه الوقت يعني امتد ساعتين
ولم نجب على كل الاسئله ان شاء الله نجيب
عنها الاسبوع القادم الامر الثاني سامحوني
اذا كانت الصوره اهتزت في بعض الاوقات او
في معظم الاوقات زي ما عالجنا مشكله
الانقطاع سوف نعالج المشكله لان احنا
حريصين ان احنا نطلع من كاميرا مش من
موبايل فشويه يعني يمكن بتقابلنا بعض
التكنيكه
فان شاء الله المره الجايه تكون الصوت
والصوره على ما يرام اشكركم والقاكم يوم
الاربعاء المقبل باذن الله الى اللقاء